hélas
[Musique]
14h sur public sénat bonjour à tous
nouvelle émission des questions
d'actualité au gouvernement vous
connaissez le principe il est simple
dans une heure les sénateurs vont
interpeller le gouvernement sur les
sujets chauds du moment le gouvernement
devra s'expliquer on va vous faire vivre
ce moment au plus près du terrain avec
nous aujourd'hui
dans l'hémicycle gérant de rhabiller
jérôme bonjour alors dites-nous sur quoi
le gouvernement est attendu aujourd'hui
et bien principalement sur la sphère du
moment l'annulation du contrat des sous
marins par à l'australie il y aura pas
moins de cinq questions sur le sujet et
le gouvernement va devoir s'expliquer à
tout à l'heure jérôme cantin calme n est
pas très loin quand inquiète en salle
des conférences quentin vous allez avoir
des ministres et sénateurs à votre micro
tout à l'heure oui bonjour steve bonjour
à tous vous connaissez le principe
effectivement je me trouvais en salle
des conférences un qui jouxte
l'hémicycle effectivement au micro
ministre et sénateur on va revenir aussi
et bien sûr la présentation du budget
avec notamment le président socialiste
de la commission des finances du sénat
merci beaucoup quentin et puis jean
masse y est avec nous jean thriller
politique sur la plateforme twitch
bonjour merci d'être avec nous alors
qu'est ce qui attend les internautes
aujourd'hui eh bien on va suivre cette
toute première séance de la nouvelle
session du sénat dernière ligne droite
avant la présidentielle très attendu et
je pense que les internautes en
attendent beaucoup notamment sur ce
fameux budget présenté ce matin merci
beaucoup à jean à tout à l'heure au
programme de cette première heure le
pass sanitaires il est en vigueur
jusqu'au 15 novembre le gouvernement
envisage de prolonger son utilisation
alors dans quelle condition et puis
surtout jusqu'à quand ça sera l'objet de
notre face à face rendez vous 14 heures
30 avec d'un côté le sénateur centriste
loïc hervé farouche opposant passe
sanitaire et de l'autre martin livre i
et sénateurs qui appartient à la
majorité présidentielle
[Musique]
mais d'abord mais d'abord gros plan sur
nos finances publiques avec cette
question emmanuel macron est il en train
de cramer la caisse l'expression et de
valérie pécresse qui reprochent au
président de dépenser sans compter à
quelques mois de la présidentielle
justement ça tombe bien le gouvernement
présente aujourd'hui le budget de l'état
pour l'année prochaine on fait le point
avec samy à deux chiffres on en reparle
juste après regardez à la fin de l'été
bruno le maire avait prévenu le
gouvernement elle est resserré la vis
sur le budget le quoi qu'il en coûte
c'est fini nous sommes passés au sur
mesure et pourtant depuis la rentrée
l'exécutif multiplie les annonces à
coups de milliards d'euros des moyens en
plus pour les forces de l'ordre après le
bobo de la sécurité des coups de pouce
aux dispositifs ma prime rénove et au
chèque énergie 'l'annonce d'un revenu
d'engagement pour les jeunes et d'un
plan daide aux indépendants en tout les
dernières promesses des manuels macron
se chiffre à au moins 5 milliards
d'euros
l'opposition l'accuse de grever les
finances publiques pour faire campagne à
sept mois de l'élection présidentielle
il n'échappe à personne en fait que là
où il avait été dit que la raison allait
revenir c'est à dire que le c'était la
fin du quoi qu'il en coûte finalement il
ya un écran de fumée c'est à dire que
des dépenses qui ne sont pas des
dépenses' à la crise sanitaire vont
devenir des dépenses pérennes nouvelles
supplémentaires sur le budget de l'état
mais qui vont s'inscrire dans la durée
donc il ya finalement c'est un peu
merlin l'enchanteur le pré la république
ces nouvelles dépenses encore difficile
à chiffrer ne figure pas dans le budget
2022 présenté aujourd'hui en conseil des
ministres un texte à trous s'inquiète le
haut conseil des finances publiques qui
s'est dit incapable de rendre un avis
sur ce budget et pour en parler j'ai le
plaisir d'accueillir sur ce plateau rémi
féraud bonjour sénateur socialiste de
paris secrétaire de la commission des
finances ainsi que didier rambaud
bonjour vous êtes sénateur marcheurs de
l'isère vice président de la commission
des finances
rémi féraud 6 milliards d'euros de
dettes 'promis annoncé un par le
gouvernement on a fait le calcul à la
rédaction de public sénat qu'est ce que
ça vous inspire
que emmanuel macron est en campagne du
matin au soir et que par ailleurs le
budget qui est présenté aujourd'hui qui
vient d'être adopté par le conseil des
ministres est incomplet pour être avons
utilisé un mot gentil ces suies de le
mot utilisé par le conseil des finances
publiques en devenir une grande partie
de ces mesures ne se retrouve pas dans
le budget donc
soit ces promesses sont des promesses en
l'air soit le budget va être modifié au
fur et à mesure de l'automne ce qui pose
un vrai problème démocratique et de
discussion parlementaire didier rambaud
c'est un budget de campagne comme ce que
dit rémi féraud il semble qu'un
président de la république et il a 5 ans
de mandat donc jusqu'au pic et la date
28 avril il va gérer le pays et il va
prendre des décisions jusqu'à cette date
là un an avant l'élection il a plus
droit de travailler puis les pilotes il
ya quand même beaucoup de mesures voilà
écoutez 1915 qu'il était lui à cinq ans
pour prendre un certain il a pris un
certain nombre d'engagements il est là
aussi au jour le jour pour continuer à
réformer pays à réparer ou si le pays si
vous a pas échappé que nous sortons
d'une crise acea ça va nous sortons
sommes en train de sortir d'une crise
sanitaire assez dur il faut en tirer les
conséquences et et ajuster effectivement
certain nombre de mesures rémi féraud
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que ça vous
inspire après tout c'est vrai que à
chaque automne avant la présidentielle
il y à des annonces et c'est pas nouveau
ça fait 30 ans que c'est toujours la
même chose oui mais si ces annonces
n'étaient pas une improvisation et
serait inscrite dans le budget qui est
présenté par le gouvernement sous
l'autorité du président de la république
donc
parle de sortir du quoi qu'il en coûte
mais faut pas non plus qu'on rentre dans
le n'importe quoi donc soit ce sont des
annonces bien réel bien travaillé bien
anticipé elles doivent être dans le
budget soit c'est du vent on va voir
d'ailleurs comment le gouvernement va
amender son propre budget au fur et à
mesure de l'automne pour intégrer ces
annonces des annonces qui sont des
annonces de campagne il ya là quelque
chose à 10 ans de campagne excuse moi de
vous couper votre candidate puisque
c'est votre candidate anne hidalgo en
fait aussi beaucoup d'annoncés pour le
pouvoir d'achat
doublement du salaire des enseignants
par exemple oui mais elle a annoncé sa
candidature de elle n'est pas au pouvoir
là on a un président de la république
candidat sans le dire mais qui vont en
effet il a été élu pour cinq ans
emmanuel macron mais si ce sont des
mesures pour ce quinquennat là elle
devrait être inscrit dans le budget qui
a été qui a été présenté ce matin c'est
quand c'est pas les oppositions qui sont
sévères avec le budget à ce stade nous
venons de le recevoir c'est le haut
conseil des finances publiques
c'est-à-dire premier président de la
cour des comptes en particulier alors on
va aussi accueillir jérôme bascher
inquiet juste là qu'il va nous rejoindre
sénateurs les républicains de loi
secrétaire de la commission des finances
jérôme bascher j'imagine que vous avez
beaucoup de choses
nous dire sur ce budget c'est un budget
de campagne c'est pas un budget campagne
qu'est ce que vous en pensez vous j'ai
beaucoup pas dire mais en tout cas
beaucoup plus que le gouvernement qui a
oublié beaucoup de dépenses dans ce
budget de budget qui est lacunaire
peu plausible nous disait ce matin
pierre moscovici qui s'y connaît
c'est effectivement un budget totalement
électoralistes on passe du quoi qu'il en
coûte aux je serai candidat coûte que
coûte et il en coûtera aux français
voilà ce qui est à être l'addition
finale alors entre temps on a des
mesures sympathique mais il ya aussi un
petit peu plausible qu'est ce que ça
veut dire concrètement qu on comprenne
quand on n'est pas des experts en
finances publiques est ce que ça veut
dire peu plausible ça veut dire que on a
par exemple
oublier un certain nombre de dépenses
comme rien d'autre que le plan
d'investissement
pour notre avenir bon au lit le budget
dans les années à venir effectivement
qu'il ya écrit dans le budget sur le
buzz dans le
dossier de presse il est écrit un
développement durable et rien dans ce
budget sur le développement durable on
voit bien qu'il va manquer plein de
choses qui sont appelés à venir on
commence par distribuer de l'argent à
tout le monde un énorme arrosage
financier pour la police pour les
infirmières partout et puis vous allez
voir qu'il va en manquer beaucoup que
chacun va venir à son tour réclamer son
dû et lorsque l'on commence par exemple
une conférence sur les salaires des
fonctionnaires en disant c'est un
chantier de très long terme pourquoi
commence-t-on ce chantier à six mois de
l'élection présidentielle
sachant que c'est un chantier de long
terme on veut juste faire des promesses
ou les cerfs pays par d'autres la parole
est à la défense didier rambaud oui j'ai
face à moi deux opposants voilà un homme
qui tombe un petit peu dans la
caricature j'suis pas sûr que les
fonctionnaires les policiers les
infirmières voire va apprécier le terme
d'arrosage amour je pense que on a
aujourd'hui on connaît leur situation
est effectivement il méritait quand même
de demain alors juste place la
revalorisation
ministères régaliens sont les plus gâtés
injuria d'armé intérieur justice attend
qu'on vienne janvier dans ce budget de
le qualifier en deux mots sérénité et et
cohérent sérénité parce que chacun
connaît aujourd'hui la situation
économique je crois qu on peut se
réjouir de la situation économique de
notre pays si on se replace un mars 2020
l'annnonce du premier confinement je
pense que tous sont au lac amance 10 et
dans quel état on va sortir ses terres
il reproche principal que c'est le
manque de transparence qu'est-ce que
vous avez pas répondre à ça non attendez
je vois très bien donc on veut parler il
ya deux dépenses effectivement qui à ce
jour ne sont pas concrètement inscrits
sur le revenu l'engagement pour les
jeunes dont il convient de travailler
encore cette mesure de bien connaître un
petit peu le périmètre et puis
effectivement le plan d'investissement
projet alors jusqu'à 2030 à hauteur de
30 milliards d'euros dont on peut
comprendre aussi qui va payer va
s'étalonner sera sans plusieurs années
donc c'est un budget qui est cohérent
parce qu'il fit correspond aux
engagements
de d'emmanuel mac ronde les missions
régaliennes sont assumés en matière de
défense de justice plus +8 % d'éducation
même l'aide publique au développement
d'ici des sujets sur lesquels nous
sommes sensibles plus 70% par rapport au
quinquennat précédent donc en 2020 on
avait un budget d'urgence faut tout pour
l'urgence en 2021 c'était tout pour la
relance et là je pense qu'effectivement
c'est 2022 c'est tout pour la roja
continue à tout pour la relance et puis
préparer la sortie de la crise mais vous
devez être content rémi féraud n'en
alors on entend la droite évidemment qui
qui qui gronde qui qui cogne contre ces
dépenses incontrôlées mais vous à gauche
il est plutôt content il ya des
revalorisations il ya des pas du tout et
pensant qu'ils vont vous diront pourquoi
parce que
la droite comme vous dites alors droite
majorité sénatoriale mais je dirais
aussi la droite gouvernementale avec
bruno le maire sont d'accord sur une
chose c'est une politique des ressources
de l'état qui préserve depuis le début
du quinquennat qui privilégie même les
nos concitoyens les plus aisés prenez-en
un exemple dans ce budget
malheureusement ce budget ne remet pas
par exemple
impôt sur la fortune pour avoir des
recettes exceptionnelles face à une
crise exceptionnelle puisque c'était la
boussole de son quinquennat mais si on
prend une autre mesure fiscale
l'engagement d' emmanuel macron des
campagnes présidentielles s'étaient de
supprimer la taxe d'habitation pour les
80 % de nos concerts vaillant et dans le
budget 2010 22 c'est prévu dans les
vingt derniers pendant
c'est à dire le contraire de
l'engagement qu'avait pris emmanuel
macron puisque emmanuel macron s'était
engagé à supprimer la taxe d'habitation
pour les 80 % des français les moins
riches et non pas pour les 20 % les plus
aisés et c'est eux qui vont en
bénéficier dans le budget 2022 alors que
nous avons un déficit considérable une
dette publique considérable et que
justement pour financer les dépenses qui
sont nécessaires nous avons un véritable
problème de ressources fiscales de
ressources de l'état juste c'est le
conseil constitutionnel qui obligeait ce
que les 20% lyssois ce qu'on peut
reprocher à mâcon effectivement c'est de
faire fi de la constitution comme il
fait fi de la constitution dans ce
budget là effectivement en disant moi je
le dis ce budget insincère il n'y a pas
inscrit les sommes annoncées donc il est
insincère voilà la vérité
quand on quand vous dites quand vous
qu'est ce que ça implique de dire qu'on
va
augmenter le déficit de 30 milliards par
exemple en mettant le plan de relance on
a une autorisation d'engagement jérôme
vous n'avez pas bien écouté ce matin ce
qu'a dit pierre moscovici et bien moi je
réponds présent quand il a dit non le
thème un sincère ne peut pas être
utilisée par le conseil des finances
publiques mais moi il a parlé d'une
parlementaire défini par la constitution
et non pas par une mission qui
voudraient se faire par lui-même mais la
cour des comptes avait dit que le budget
était un sincère en 2010 7e on se
souvient c'était celui vous aviez voté
l'un et l'autre des
landes mais
c'était déjà je suis pas me permettre cd
oui ou non mais je sais bien qu'on peut
toujours se dédouaner avoir changé de
camp plusieurs fois pour changer d'avis
plusieurs fois c'est plus simple que son
foie mais on peut aussi être constant et
la constance là dessus c'est de dire que
depuis 2000 21 le gouvernement se moque
du parlement en changeant et en
annonçant des choses après le vote des
lois de finances et lois finances sont
votés rectificative il y en a autant
comme au temps et dès le lendemain dès
le jour même parfois d'autres annonces
sont faites il se moque du parlement
comme il se moque des français et ce
budget en vérité se moque des français
alors tout le monde n'a pas entendu
pierre moscovici 1 ce matin donc on va
peut-être leur et ont de la chance ce
budget et qui visiblement ne comptant
pas ne convainc pas grand monde en tout
cas ne convainc pas tout le monde le
haut conseil des finances publiques
s'est fâché tout rouge aujourd'hui vous
allez écouter son président il était
entendu ce matin par la commission des
finances
pour 2022 le haut conseil a été saisi
sur une base incomplète s'agissant des
dépenses qui ne contiennent pas
certaines mesures importantes que le
gouvernement souhaite voir adopter par
amendement faute d'information sur le
chiffrage ces mesures manquantes le haut
conseil ne peut pas à ce stade se
prononcer sur le caractère plausible ou
non du sol de public dont il est saisi
au titre du plf 2022 troisième et
dernier message la sortie de crise
meilleurs que prévu le caractère
particulier y compris sur le plan
politique d'un 2022 ne doit pas masquer
que nos finances publiques sorte de la
crise marqué par un niveau d'endettement
inédit depuis la seconde guerre mondiale
et des dynamiques différentes en
recettes et en dépenses et que tout ceci
appelle la plus grande vigilance un
projet de finances un complet didier
rambaud vous trouvez ça c'est vers
nous et je pense que j'ai dû pierre
moscovici joue son rôle moi moi je vous
savez un président de cour des comptes
et au type les idées plaie pour les
opposants et aux autres donc il a tout à
fait raison ce qu'il a dit ce matin
voilà c'est un conte périph items ans il
ya encore deux mesures qui mérite d'être
inscrits moi je suis très serein par
rapport à ça ça va arriver avant
l'examen parce que là c'est
constitutionnel ça va arriver avant
l'examen à l'assemblée nationale on aura
effectivement donc ce sera fait ce que
vous veniez c'est une question tu as
encore ben oui voilà il faut il faut
finaliser le le ces deux mesures voilà
revenu d'engagement pour les jeunes ça
va être une mesure sociale importante
qui va concerner la note de notre
jeunesse dont elle mérite d'être préparé
un mot sur la question de la fiscalité
parce que j'ai entendu le collègue rémi
féraud reproché gentiment
de ne pas avoir toucher à la fiscalité
c'est un engagement là aussi le
président de la république de
fictivement de stopper la hausse des
prélèvements obligatoires d'ailleurs
pour la première fois depuis 2011 le
taux des prélèvements obligatoires va
baisser à 43 6 % plus de 50 milliards
d'euros de baisses d impôts à la fois
pour les entreprises et les particuliers
rajoutant la suppression de la taxe
d'habitation alors il est clair willy sf
a été supprimé et on a su mois là on ne
veut pas créer effectivement une
catégorie d'exilés fiscaux parce que je
considère qu'il faut c'est un budget un
peu en même temps un peu de droite un
peu de gauche qui l'a écoutée oui je
crois que c'est pas un secret pour
personne que oui autant d' emmanuel
macron il ya des gens qui viennent de la
droite et de la gauche dont je suis
parti allez on va on va retrouver quand
un chalmé qui est en salle les
références quentin vous êtes avec claude
raynal président socialiste de la
commission des finances il était aux
premières loges d'un tout à l'heure
pendant l'audition de pierre moscovici
oui tout à fait c'est elle et lui
inquiété et bien à l'origine de
l'invitation à pierre moscovici bonjour
claude raynal séquence président
socialiser la commission des finances a
ici au sénat un mot sur et bien ce
discours de pierre moscovici devant la
commission lorsqu'il parle d'un budget
incomplet est ce à dire que ce budget
insincère peux pas le dire comme ça
l'insincérité il l'a rappelé d'ailleurs
c'est plutôt quelque chose que l'on
clope est décrété sur l'exécution après
exécution et on peut comparer le budget
présenté le budget réalisé et là on peut
parler éventuellement d'insincérité
c'est arrivé d'ailleurs très rarement
point que le haut conseil qualifie un
budget des inserts il faut remonter
maintenant très loin et alors un budget
incomplet est-ce que se pose pas un
problème démocratique comme disait ma
collègue et rémi féraud à l'instant sur
le poteau de steve jourdain lorsque on
examine un projet de finances avec des
trous je crois d'ailleurs s'est relevé
là aussi c'est la première fois qu'on a
un nom au conseil qui est aussi sévère
finalement sur ce le document qu'il a
été transmis et pour cette raison là
parce qu'il ya un certain nombre de
sujets qui ne sont pas traités dans le
plf alors qu'on sait qu'ils vont arriver
non seulement c'est qui va arriver mais
je veux dire ce ne sont pas des mesures
conjoncturelles on pourrait comprendre
qu'en cours de plf on examine des
mesures nouvelles liées à une situation
particulière qui nécessite de prendre un
peu de temps là c'est pas le cas on est
sur des mesures quand une vocation à
être pérennisées en tout cas pour celles
pour l'engagement des jeunes très
clairement
milliards d'euros c'est deux milliards
d'euros mais qui vont être pérennisé
voyez ce que je veux donc sont des
travaux préparatoires qu'il faut faire
avant la présentation du budget même
chose pour le plan d'investissement qui
est quand même de long terme c'est quand
même curieux qu'on n'est pas des le
budget au moins le coût pour 2022 tout à
fait votre premier à porter c'est
jean-françois son rapporteur général du
budget au sénat il parle de vannes
complètement grande ouverte la carte
bancaire du gouvernement dit-il est
devenue folle est-ce que là dessus et la
gauche est d'accord en commission des
finances il ya deux aspects là dedans
est-ce qui a besoin de dépenses
publiques dans des secteurs donnés on
parle
engagement pour la jeunesse les
socialistes l'ont demandé depuis le
début de la crise et c'est bien avec
retard qu'on s'intéresse à cette
question et on le sent bien qu'il ya un
côté préélectorale plutôt qu'un côté
réponse la jeunesse je le regrette il
fallait un an dès 2020 mettre en route
cela donc de ce point de vue là oui
est-ce que globalement il y à il ya des
sujets la nature après lectorale la
réponse est oui est ce que la dépense
publique doit être regardée avec une
vision plus positive que simplement dire
il faut tous fermés et réduire
l'endettement et consacrer toutes les
recettes nouvelles à la baisse de
l'endettement la réponse et nous un
dernier mot que de reynal puisque
positionné à 17 heures le ministre de
l'économie et également olivier dussopt
pts le ministre du budget quel est votre
message à ses deux ministres qui
vénissieux au sénat a voulu découvrir
d'avertir aussi non mais ils savent déjà
il savait bien qu'elle va quelle va être
notre réaction la réaction si vous
voulez c'est qu'il n'est pas normal que
dans un projet de loi de finances
n'oublions pas la totalité des sujets
qu'ils soient traités dès le départ et
qu'on travaille ensuite par un
amendement dans la session tout ça n'est
pas raisonnable merci beaucoup un claude
raynal je rappelle que vous êtes le
président socialiste de la commission
des finances ici au sénat à vous et
merci beaucoup quand on retrouve tout à
l'heure avant de vous faire réagir
j'aimerais qu'on qu'on écoute justement
bruno le maire bruno le maire qui
présentait tout à l'heure en sortie du
conseil des ministres qui présentait le
budget 2022 écoutez le et choix qui sont
dans ce pv sont très claires c'est un
choix dans les armements et galien 1,17
milliard d'euros pour les armes et 700
millions d'euros pour la justice 1,5
milliard d'euros pour le ministère de
l'intérieur avec le bourg où la sécurité
les français veulent de la protection il
veut de la sécurité ils veulent une
justice plus rapide ils veulent de la
lutte contre la délinquance il veut de
la protection contre les grandes menaces
stratégiques au premier rang desquels le
terrorisme nous leur apportons dans ce
budget la réponse qu'ils attendent nous
engageons aussi dans ce budget pour 2022
la fin du quoi qu'il en coûte
nous ne laissons pas si les dépenses
nous n'ouvrons pas tout grand le
chéquier au contraire nous avons le
courage de dire que désormais que la
croissance est de retour nous mettons
fin aux quoiqu'il ans jérôme vachin vous
avez l'air consterné c'est totalement
faux 12 milliards de plus de dépenses
courantes alors je veux bien là il va
faire les sommes sur le régalien
d'accord très bien c'est un quart de la
csdc 12 me au salut et il met le paquet
sur le gouvernement dernier arrêté sur
le régalien sur 12 milliards de dépenses
courantes en a 3 milliards sur régalien
ce qui est de dire c'est pas la même
chose donc c'est pas le paquet il paquet
faudrait aussi que les économies qu'ils
soient proposées hélas le courage
politique c'est de dire où on met des
économies et comme on n'en dit pas parce
qu'on en fait pas et une honnêteté
totale c'est on ne dit pas qu'on fait
des économies car on n'en fait aucune
vous savez que la france par rapport à
ces pays concurrents européens où ces
pays amis maintenant où ces pays il faut
se méfier c'était le pays qui était en
2010 est le dernier de la classe
européenne eh bien ça et vous que en
2022 ne seront toujours les derniers
voilà le projet d' emmanuel macron pour
nos finances publiques et pour le
rétablissement de la france digne et
rambo ya aucune aucune économie
ils révisent sur le budget 2011 de l'ue
des mesures courageuses côté prise en
début de ce quinquennat lorsqu'on a
supprimé les contrats aidés sap a fait
plaisir lorsqu'on à réformer le
financement de action logement ça n'a
pas fait plaisir lorsqu'on a à réformer
les financements des chambres de
commerce et d'industrie tout le monde
hurlait moi j'étais à la tension un peu
sur les contradictions des oppositions
qui va d'un côté il ya trop de dépenses
en fait pas assez d'efforts et puis vous
allez voir dans quelques semaines ce qui
va se passer au parlement quand on va
voter mission par mission prendre le
mans les occasions ont voté contre parce
que vont dire c'est pas assez le compte
n'y est pas voilà donc je veux dire
qu'est ce qu'on fait concrètement voilà
donc c'est un peu je pense qu'il ya une
espèce d'équilibré à trouver
effectivement entre assurer l'avenir de
notre pays est pas une et ses dérivés
non plus les finances alors moi j'ai une
idée pour financer tout ça il ya quand
même peut-être une petite cagnotte de
l'été avec cette croissance qui arrive
on parle de 6% cette année 4 % pour 2022
elle est là la cagnotte pour financer
toutes ces mesures rémi féraud c'est pas
une question de de cagnotte par ailleurs
là aussi sur les recettes pierre
moscovici a dit que la copie du
gouvernement étaient incomplètes et ray
est très incertaine à ce stade moi je ne
crois pas qu'on puisse aborder le débat
budgétaire de cette manière là où d'une
certaine manière entre vous deux
opposition des républicains majorité
gouvernementale vous vous disputez pour
savoir qui est bien conforme aux canons
de la droite libérale sur les dépenses
publiques etc le la question à se poser
dans cette sortie de crise et celle de
la justice sociale celle du changement
de modèle celle de la dette aussi et
emmanuel macron en ne voulant pas mettre
à contribution les entreprises ou les
plus aisés et même en continuant de
baisser leurs impôts c'est aussi le
président du déficit public donc je
pense qu'il faut poser les visions de
manière 4% cette année 4 8% en 2022 sur
le déficit c'est réalise au pierre
moscovici a dit que ça n'était pas
irréaliste mais que ça n'était pas
réaliste en fait ça ne s'inscrit pas
dans le réel ou n'en sais rien
d'irréaliste on n'en sait rien c'est
plutôt pifométrique j'ai l'impression à
ce stade puisque il ya beaucoup
d'incertitudes en termes de recettes ça
à la limite par rapport à l'évolution de
la conjoncture on ne peut pas en vouloir
au gouvernement on est dans une
situation très mouvante en termes de
croissance et une grande incertitude en
matière de dépenses et les dépenses de
l'état dans qui vont être ajoutés cet
automne je crois que c'est vraiment un
problème démocratique que ce soit juste
les annonces de campagne égrené au fur
et à mesure par emmanuel macron les
parlementaires ils ont besoin de pouvoir
étudier le budget globalement
sincèrement et complète du rhône bachir
sur le déficit peut être
historiquement je vous invite à regarder
ça depuis 1981 il n'y a eu aucune année
où l'élection présidentielle dan
élection présidentielle où le déficit a
été tenue
jamais on fait un projet de déficit
alors plus ou moins pour 100 g ou un
sincère comme en 2010 est carrément un
sincère pas cour des comptes l'avait dit
la cour des comptes l'avait dit
et après l'élection présidentielle il
faut mettre en place les promesses
présidentielles et on met d'abord en
place ce qui coûte donc vous avez
commencé avec un déficit de 4,8 7% 4,5
peu importe et vous allez finir l'année
2022 un bon point au dessus voilà ce qui
va se faire parce que y'a presque en
toute confidence du nord où on arrose et
je maintiens que l'on arrose il aurait
fallu faire ces mesures avant le beauvau
le bobo c'était c'est vraiment le
dernier moment d'élection présidentielle
la conférence sur les finances plus sur
les la fonction publique c'est juste
avant l'élection présidentielle le ségur
c'est juste avant le
juste avant l'élection présidentielle
dans la crise est là de minami soma 18
ses sorties le bridge et 35 heures à
l'hôpital ça n'arrive donc ça non non
c'est pas
ceux ci à des éléments de contexte
chèque énergie ça intervient parce
qu'effectivement il ya eu une flambée
actuellement qu'est ce qu'on fait il ya
donc entre martine aubry et emmanuel
macron il ya eu aussi nicolas sarkozy
nous faut c'est qu'on soir je vois pas
le rapport mais sur le tristement rien
je pense
une question peut-être plus
philosophique on va dire l'austérité
c'est terminé ce qu'on est entré
finalement dans une nouvelle ère
aujourd'hui des dépenses publiques et
des finances publiques en général lire
en mono non au contraire moi je
considère qu'il faut continuer à être
très rigoureux vigilant sur la la tenue
de nos finances publiques parce que bon
on peut pas laisser non plus de déraper
une dette c'est ce sont nos enfants et
nos petits enfants qui qu'ils arriveront
et s'est affirmé dans leur danse plf
qu'effectivement il faut ici tellement
maintenant attention il faut retourner à
un retour retrouver des déficits
acceptable de faire baisser la dette
stabiliser voire baisser les styles et
des prélèvements obligatoires et c'est
ce qui sera fait lorsque deux pour ce
plf 2022 rémi féraud les taux d'intérêt
sont très bas c'est le moment d'investir
oui c'est même pas dû d'ailleurs lié
uniquement au taux d'intérêt il y a
besoin d'investir en particulier dans la
transition écologique et violence euros
ce budget est très conservateur c'est
voilà c'est mon continue sur la même
ligne depuis le début du quinquennat il
ne dégage pas les ressources nécessaires
pour financer les grandes transitions
dans notre pays a besoin et il fait
toujours peser l'essentiel de la
fiscalité sur la classe moyenne et la
classe populaire sans dégager assez de
ressources c'est cela que nous
contestons le mot de la fin il est pour
vous jérôme bascher sûr finalement la
faim ou pas de l'austérité pour les
avenirs les années à venir il n'y a pas
d'austérité il n'y a pas eu d'austérité
nous avons eu la pire augmentation de la
dette dans l'union européenne nous avons
eu la pire augmentation historique de la
dette nous sommes libéraux aujourd'hui
le quoi le en même temps c'est libéral
sur les recettes
socialiste sur les dépenses ça ne marche
pas merci merci à tous les trois merci
d'avoir participé à ce débat les
questions d'actualité vont démarrer dans
maintenant trente deux minutes très
précisément tout le monde est en place
vous le voyez sur votre écran quand un
calme et en salle des conférences jean
mas il sur twitter et jérôme rabier qui
est au coeur de la machine germain
crabiers qui est dans l'hémicycle jérôme
donnez nous le programme un programme un
très dominés par là cette vente annulée
par l'australie des sous-marins français
c'est la question brûlante du moment et
évidemment les sénateurs s'en empare il
y aura aujourd'hui cinq questions
d'actualité dédié à ce sujet pour
aborder tous les aspects de cette crise
l'aspect diplomatique bien sûr alors que
le bras de fer continue entre la france
et l'australie entre la france et le
royaume uni entre la france et les états
unis l'aspect financier les conséquences
sur l'emploi aussi puisque navale groupe
1 qui avait engagé des dépenses et
recruter du personnel pour fabriquer ces
sous-marins et bien maintenant
s'interroge sur la suite et notamment un
dédommagement et enfin l'aspect
politique les sénateurs socialistes ont
annoncé qu'ils demandent la création
d'une commission denquête le sujet a été
mis sur la table hier selon
l'information à la conférence des
présidents qui se tenait ici au sénat
autour de gérard larcher y avait tous
les présidents de groupe et les
présidents de commissions et bien la
majorité
de droite et du centre 1 du sénat n'a
pas fermé la porte à cette création
d'une commission denquête mais christian
cambon le président l ère de la
commission des affaires étrangères de la
défense et des forces armées veut
d'abord faire les choses dans l'ordre il
veut auditionner les responsables les
ministres tous les acteurs de ce dossier
et seulement si des zones d'ombré
persistent il en sera cette commission
denquête le gouvernement et prévenu le
sénat attend des réponses et bien ça
peut démarrer dans une demi heure avec
cette séance de questions d'actualité au
gouvernement et on sera au rendez vous
giro merci beaucoup à tout à l'heure on
passe à présent au second thème de cette
émission le pass sanitaire stop ou
encore sur le papier les choses en sont
plutôt simples le gouvernement peut
imposer le pass sanitaire jusqu'au 15
novembre le 15 novembre
c'est pas tout de suite mais c'est
demain en cas de nouvelle vague en cas
de cinquième vague à l'automne ou à
l'hiver qu'est ce qu'on fait est ce que
le pass sanitaire est un outil
indispensable pour freiner l'épidémie
c'est la question que je vais vous poser
à tous les deux messieurs bonjour merci
d'être avec nous le lot et qu'hervé
sénateur centriste de haute-savoie
membre de la commission des lois bonjour
avant d'être là martin lévriers
sénateurs marcheurs des yvelines et g10
président de la commission des affaires
sociales bonjour merci d'être là avant
de vous entendre un tous les deux ont
fait le point sur le dossier sanitaire
un conseil de défense était organisée ce
matin sur la question prudence prudence
nous dit gabriela talent en sortie du
conseil des ministres mais des
allègements ont été avancées regardez ce
sujet il est signé jeremy hunt man
alors que la situation épidémique
s'améliore en france le gouvernement
commencent à desserrer l'étau à l'issue
du conseil de défense sanitaire ce
mercredi l'exécutif a décidé de lever
certaines restrictions dans les
territoires où le virus circule moins
vite à partir du lundi 4 octobre dans
les départements où le taux d'incidence
se stabilise au dessous du seuil de 50
pour cent mille habitants le protocole
scolaire passera en niveau 1 ce qui
signifie essentiellement que
l'obligation du port du masque à l'école
primaire il sera levé deuxième mesure
les jauges qui s'applique dans certains
établissements recevant du public seront
levés dans ces mêmes départements des
assouplissements qui concerne pour
l'instant 41 départements passé sous le
seuil d'alerté mais le gouvernement se
montre aussi prudent face à une
éventuelle reprise épidémique redouté
dès cet automne par certains membres du
conseil scientifique
l'exécutif refuse pour le moment une
adaptation locale du pass sanitaires et
veut d'ailleurs le prolonger au delà du
15 novembre date actuelle de fin du
dispositif une position qui divise les
parlementaires je ne suis pas favorable
à cet outil à cet outil qui est un outil
qui est grave au regard de la liberté de
circulation donc évidemment je n'étais
pas pour sa mise en place je ne suis pas
pour sa prolongation j'y suis favorable
à une condition c'est que cette
prolongation ne se fasse pas jusqu après
l'élection présidentielle mais qu'il
faut aussi qu'on ait des clauses de
rendez vous au parlement le parlement
siège jusqu'au mois de février et je
pense qu'une prolongation jusqu'au mois
de février serait la bienvenue le projet
de loi prorogeant le pass sanitaire sera
présenté le 13 octobre en conseil des
ministres on va parler bien évidemment
du pass sanitaire mais juste avant ça
j'aimerais vous entendre messieurs sur
ces annonces du gouvernement tout à
l'heure le hic harvey la levée de
l'obligation du port du masque à l'école
primaire à partir du 4 octobre dans
certaines dans certains départements où
le taux d'incidence est très faible
c'est une bonne mesure c'est une mesure
nécessaire selon vous absolument
j'enlève ma casquette de sénateur et je
procède de père de famille et je vous
dis que dans les écoles il est
indispensable que dès qu'on le peut on
retire cette obligation du port du
masque qui pose tout un tas de
difficultés en terme d'apprentissage
l'école est un lieu de socialisation
c'est un lieu d'être on va apprendre à
lire à écrire à parler à communiquer et
quand la bouche de l'enseignant et la
bouche des enfants est couverte d'un
masque évidemment il ya beaucoup de
choses qui ne passent plus et dans ces
échanges d'apprentissage mais très laid
qui sont essentiels et je vous le dis
encore une fois en tant que père de
famille pour moi c'est une bonne
nouvelle et je me réjouis tout
gouvernement ait annoncé ça alors par
contre aucune levée du pass sanitaire
pour le moment même dans les
départements le taux d'incidence est
faible vous le comprenez ça la première
chose je rejoins totalement ce que dit
mon combo collègues sur le fait qu'on
est surtout j'ajoute un point que vous
n'avez pas cité c'est que ces
territorialisées je trouve que cette
démarche est très intéressante et très
intelligente à partir du moment où on
les fait de façon peu commune
intéressante avec les territoires et
avec des critères précis cinquante pour
cent mille voilà on connaît on connaît
la règle du jeu on la comprend à
l'éclair elle est progressive elle est
intelligente donc tout va bien et elle
protège en termes sanitaires
concernant le concernant le pass n y
était en tant que tel
là nous serons probablement des hackers
moi je considère que c'est un excellent
outil c'est un outil qui a fait ses
preuves on l'a vu cet été on a pu le
comparer avec ce qui se passait dans
d'autres territoires qu'ils ont moins
bien appliquées ou qui n'ont pas
vaccinés comme qui n'ont pas suivi le
mouvement de vaccination comme l'a fait
la métropole je pense aux outre-mer donc
on a très bien vu l'impact de ce pass
sanitaires on voit très bien qu'il est
particulièrement appréciée par la
plupart des français il suffit d'aller
se promener d'aller dans des bars
d'aller dans des restaurants d'aller
apprécier c'est possiblement après c'est
très étonnant et ben oui et moi tout la
plupart des gens j'ai eu quelques
réfractaires qui j'ai discuté d'ailleurs
longuement mais la plupart des gens mais
ça a un côté rassurant ça prend trois
secondes et finalement c'est c'est pas
désagréable du tout donc moi je suis
très content de ce de cette
appropriation et qui sait qu'il faut le
prolonger pour il n'ya pas
d'inconvénient à prolonger se passer ni
terre torse avec la question alors il ya
la pandémie temps c'est nécessaire c'est
nécessaire tout ce qui est utile combien
la fin de la pandémie c'est pas pour
tout de suite par mon visiblement écouté
en france on l'a quand même et 200
certains pays européens et d'autres je
pense à israël on a quand même
considérablement avancé de ce côté là le
vaccin est un outil extraordinaire qui
nous soignent pas ne l'oublions pas qui
prendra effet dès mai le gist arnaud
fontanet membres du conseil sur
magnifique ce matin dans le parisien y
met en garde l'épidémie pourrait
repartir à l'automne c'est pas tout
c'est pas terminé d'où l'intérêt du pass
le pass sanitaire eux et qu'ils feront
accoutumance c'est à dire que ce risque
d'aller comme dans un escalier marche
après marche vers quelque chose qui
s'installe ce que nous avions annoncé
nous avions prévenu qu'on irait vers
cela alors la main sur le coeur au mois
de au mois d'avril nous gagnerons pas de
généralisation au mois de juillet ce
sera temporaire et bien maintenant on
est dans quelque chose de durable le
pass sanitaire n'a aucun intérêt sur un
plan sanitaire il a un intérêt que je
reconnais qu'ils aient le fait d'avoir
convaincu à la vaccination soit un
certain nombre de nos compatriotes qui
se sont fait vacciner essentiellement
pour partir en vacances sans avoir été
profondément convaincu de la dimension
avec six nations deux jeux suivants
12 juillet et donc j'ai
donc si l'objectif était d'atteindre 85
% des vaccinés parmi les incunables on y
est donc le passé il ya eu un autre
effet dont personne ne parle c'est qu'il
a radicalisé les antilles et à la
différence de l'espagne ou de
l'angleterre où le poulpe assez rester
quelques semaines eh bien on est on est
on sait pas on n'a pas une approche de
santé publique ou une approche de
confiance et de conviction d'une
approche de coercition il faut qu'on
explique quel est l'intérêt du passe
quand on sait aujourd'hui que la science
nous a démontré que le virus circule
entre vacciner
l'idée de dix mois attendez
c'est pas faux c'est pas faux le degré
est différent que par ailleurs le lieu
de contamination principal notamment en
entretenant vacciner c'est le domicile
c'est la sphère privée et dieu soit loué
j'espère qu'on ira pas réglementer la
vie des français chez eux à ce moment là
le pas s'y perdre une grande partie son
intérêt mais je suis je je je je crains
mais je c'est normal j'ai déjà une un
parcours à la cnil un parcours à
commission des lois qui fait que ces
questions libertés publiques mais
voilà j'ai une forme de
noeud préoccupations et je me dis mais
quelle est l'étape d'après quoi je veux
dire est ce que ce pass sanitaire
valurent abbas vaccinale est ce que
demain on va comme l'école grec
socialiste le propose vaccination
c'est obligatoire et impasses sanitaire
devenu basée à kinshasa dans l'escalier
nommé dans l'escalier on peut les encore
très loin et c'est pour ça que
j'aimerais moi je pense qu'il faut qu'on
arrête le le passage de la phase aller
le plus vite possible on n'est pas livré
j'aimerais entendre matt arrivée sur
cette question de regard totalement
différent d'abord le pass sanitaire a
été votée c'est une loi donc dire que
c'est un une suppression de liberté
n'est pas logique toute loi où 99% des
lois peuvent être une contrainte de
liberté sont originales des contraintes
de liberté pour certains par rapport à
d'autres donc si le législateur prend
des décisions il est bien normal qu'elle
soit appliquée c'est une loi qui a été
votée par les deux parlements par les
deux chambres proposées par le
gouvernement et qui a été voté donc allé
d'une loi et donc elle rentre dans notre
principe de démocratie et dans ce qui
fait nation dire que c'est liberticide
dire que non nous l'avons voté alors que
vous soyez dans la minorité c'est votre
droit et que vous ayez envie de défendre
ça oui mais dire que c'est liberticide
ça n'a pas de sens ça n'a pas de sens
parce que c'est la démocratie qui
l'emporté c'est essentiel ils ont
répondu c'est très près de ses très
pédagogique on l'a bien vu ça ça vous
l'avez dit on l'a on l'a très bien vu ça
a été très efficace pour que les gens
aient envie de se vacciner et ce n'était
pas une obligation vaccinale
c'était tout l'intérêt du jeu c'était de
dire écoutez on crée un certain nombre
de contraintes pour vous inciter à vous
vacciner mais si vous ne voulez pas vous
pouvez continuer gratuitement un
ministre une vie
je finis donc donc on peut ne pas être
vaccinés et profiter du pass and it et
ce qui est essentiel donc il ya toujours
cet espace entre guillemets d'une forme
de liberté je sais pas où se situe la
liberté par rapport à tous hommes moi je
ne la situe pas comme ça pour moi la
liberté c'est le livre ensemble donc
c'est fair nation et fair nation c'est à
travers les lois que nous faisons donc
je n'ai pas de problème avec le pass
anita de ce côté là mais comme vous
j'espère qu'il va disparaître vite parce
que s'il disparaît vite ça veut dire que
la pandémie et d'ariane alors on a une
des attentes déjà on a eu d'assez le 15
novembre 15 novembre et bien le
gouvernement ne peut plus imposer ce
pass sanitaire le texte de loi ne le
permet pas alors qu'est ce qu'on fait
est ce qu'il va falloir tronche un texte
de loi va être présenté en conseil des
ministres début octobre qu'est ce que
vous allez faire avec ce tacle cettex le
kers est une vraie question de principe
parce que martin lévriers vient de dire
que la loi il ya le vrai 6 et le 9 août
et jusqu'au 15 novembre à 15 novembre le
conseil d'état et le conseil
constitutionnel
et nous au parlement avons considéré
majoritairement pas moins avec
majoritairement que les circonstances
exceptionnelles je précise du variant
delta au moment la quatrième vague au
début de l'été justifier la mise en
place du moins l'extension de ce pass
sanitaires pour vous ce n'est pas
prolongé le passé naturel 15 devant
mener aujourd'hui pas justifié partir du
moment où vous êtes à 85% des vaccinable
qui sont vaccinés à partir du moment où
on est plus dans une nouvelle
vague de l'épidémie il faut se
débarrasser du pass sanitaires encore
une fois c'est pas parce que la loi a
créé cette atteinte à la liberté d'aller
et venir atteinte à la liberté d'accès à
des rp une réalité c'est une réalité
aujourd'hui que elle doit être pérenne
ce ce virus il a eu comme conséquence de
faire qu'un certain nombre de nos
grandes libertés ont été mises entre
parenthèses pendant pendant un certains
nombre conséquent de moi avec le conflit
avec le pass et non avec le bar au même
titre que vous me diriez cas sens
interdit est une contrainte de liberté
certes pour celui qui veut aller chez
lui qui doit faire un grand tour c'est
une contrainte mais c'est une liberté
aussi donc vous ne pouvez pas dire ça
parce que ça a été voté je le redis et
moi je suis très content pour remettre l
ouvrage cette loi le 15 novembre bien
évidemment alors alors il ya un problème
le problème c'est le calendrier c'est
pas le calendrier c'est le virus où seul
le prenne dans cette humilité qu'on doit
avoir par rapport à cette cette
cochonnerie j'ai pas d'autres mots c'est
qu'il nous a il est très retors il est
très malin il nous surprend chaque fois
souvenez vous il ya un an à la même
époque il y avait à peu près qu'une
personne qui alertait en disant
attention ça repart ça va mal s'est-elle
mise de la santé personne n'a voulu
écouter d'ailleurs à l'époque on voulait
terrain territorialisée on n'arrêtait
pas dire c'est les territoires qui
doivent tous prendre et on a vu ce qui
s'est passé à marseille où marseille a
refusé les ce que proposait paris par il
l'a imposé et bien heureusement puisque
ça s'envole est complètement marcel dont
je dis attention ayant beaucoup
d'humilité le 15 en jeu vous dire que
moi je ne sais pas au 15 novembre ce qui
ce qu'il sera de la pandémie donc
principe de précaution on ne sait pas on
prolonge vais passer milan le 15
novembre si le 15 novembre tout va
vraiment bien parce qu'effectivement la
vaccination continue à être efficace
parce que s'il ya un nouveau variant ce
que je ne souhaite pas mais ce n'est pas
impossible que ce nouveau variant est
maîtrisée par là par là par la
vaccination tout va bien alors j'ai
qui sont actuellement sur la terre vous
allez devoir vous prononcer là-dessus 1
messieurs les sénateurs si on prolonge
on prolonge jusqu'à quand du 15 novembre
jusqu'à la fin mars ou du 15 novembre
jusqu'à la fin juillet si je vous pose
la question c'est que c'est important il
ya des élections présidentielle et des
élections législatives est ce qu'il faut
enjamber ces élections oui ou non selon
vous je suis incapable de vous répondre
parce que j'ai appris lui j'ai appris
j'avais j'étais jaloux très humble
objets considérer que l'humilité était
essentiel par rapport à ça et en
fonction de nouveaux virus on venait
d'une évolution du virus pardon
soyons prudents ce que vérité
d'aujourd'hui ne sera malheureusement
pas vérité de demain donc c'est vraiment
mon rêve ce que je souhaiterais vraiment
c'est qu'il n'y ait plus besoin du pass
sanitaires aux quinze ans je ne tiens
pas je n'ai aucun amour pour ce pas
sanitaires c'est un outil qui a prouvé
son efficacité
pendant cette pandémie ne jetons pas
tous les outils qui ont été efficaces et
utiles avant d'être relativement serein
mais qui revêt sur le calendrier non moi
je pense qu'il faut qu'on se débarrasse
de ce pass a été le plus le plus vite
possible brasser du vir l'art ce que
parce que nous avons atteint un niveau
de vaccination qui est désormais élevé
et qui normalement devrait nous
permettre d'avoir normalement une
capacité d'avoir une limitation du
nombre de personnes admises en service
de réanimation on en parlait s'arrêter
là le l'élément déterminant tout le
temps pour la gestion de crise
le derrière des personnes qui tombent
malades et les personnes histoire
asymptomatique et les personnes qui
développent des formes bénignes et
personnes qui développent des formes
très grave et on n'est rien d'autre nous
on a mis le pays sous cloche à plusieurs
reprises parce que le système
hospitalier mais était en incapacité ou
risquer d'être en capacité d'admettre
les les passions les plus graves en
service de réanimation en soins
intensifs donc à partir la question
c'est que si on remonte à bourg est-ce
que ce risque existe toujours encore oui
avec 85% de vaccinés oui parmi les
vaccinable vous avez un exemple simple
aujourd'hui à vic cinq cent mille
personnes ne plus de caisses 75 ans ne
sont pas vaccinés et ce sont ces
personnes alors les plus à risques que
fait sont alors allés vers
j'ai un message que vous allez partager
avec moi et je fais appel aux médecins
généralistes qui maintenant ont accès
est depuis longtemps depuis trois mois
mais qui ont du mal à l'utiliser je fais
un appel le plus fort possible à tous
les médecins généralistes qu'ils
appellent leurs patients qui ne sont pas
vaccinés ils ont la capacité de le faire
aujourd'hui il en ressort une barre à
ses élèves une urgence absolue mais là
c'est une demande qu'on fait je vais pas
ordonner je vais pas faire une loi pour
donner aux médecins de téléphoner la loi
a permis la loi a permis que les
médecins traitants puisse demander à la
caisse primaire d'assurance la liste de
leurs noms vacciner c'est sa passion
c'est la fin de ce duel sur ce sujet
merci à tous les deux mais vous restez
vous restez avec nous parce que vous
faire réagir aux autres thèmes de
l'actualité on va tout de suite retrouvé
jean mas siégeant 15 minutes des
questions d'actualité maintenant vous
allez les suivre ces questions
d'actualité pour nous avec votre
communauté sur twitter
oui absolument steve ya deux sujets qui
intéressent particulièrement les
internautes aujourd'hui pour cette
séance de questions d'actualité au
gouvernement d'abord c'est ce qu'on
appelle maintenant la crise des
sous-marins et est ce un véritable
camouflet pour la diplomatie française
pour son influence pour sa crédibilité
est ce que c'est un camouflet personnel
pour jean yves le drian pour emmanuel
macron c'est des questions qu'on se pose
et sur lesquelles on voudrait avoir des
réponses et puis sur la suite du
programme qu'est ce qui va se passer on
sait que d un appel téléphonique est
prévue entre le chef de l'état français
et son homologue américain joe biden
pour voilà peut-être régler des comptes
et puisque ça remet en cause la place de
la france dans l'alliance
transatlantique voilà ce sont des
questions qu'on se pose et sur lesquels
on espère que cet après midi au sénat le
gouvernement pourra s'exprimer un autre
sujet qui intéresse les internautes
c'est la fin du pass sanitaire dans
certains départements c'est envisagé
après le après le conseil de défense
sanitaire de ce matin la situation
s'améliore est ce qu'on va pouvoir
abandonner le pas cette année terre dans
certains départements si oui lesquelles
à quelles conditions on aimerait bien
entendre cet après midi olivier ferrand
devant les sénateurs pour s'exprimer sur
ce sujet et la mise en oeuvre de
l'obligation vaccinale auprès des
soignants comment ça se passe on a
entendu de la tension dans certains
territoires je pense notamment à
mulhouse joue dans le sud donc voilà il
ya des tensions semble-t-il est ce que
le gouvernement pourrait nous faire un
point voilà un petit peu les sujets qu
attendent les internautes sujets chauds
programme chargé merci beaucoup de gens
se retrouvent tout à l'heure j'aimerais
vous faire réagir à cette crise des sous
marins dont il sera évidemment question
lors de ces questions d'actualité au
gouvernement
on a appris qu aurait pas de commission
denquête à l'assemblée nationale là
dessus richard ferrand a dit niet y aura
pas de commission ici je m'adresse à
vous le look hervé commission des lois
il y aura une commission évoque une
commission d' enquête
sur cette affaire des sous marins ce que
vous nous confirmez déjà quand j'ai rien
contre mais je
président
président je crois pas que c'était un
petit a été évoquée je crois qu'ils ce
qui a été évoqué et envisagé mais a
confirmé ce n'est pas contre la
commission des affaires étrangères se
dote des pouvoirs d'une commission
denquête c'est très intéressant de
procéder ainsi entendement de la
commission des lois ont fait la même
chose pour la commission denquête dit
benalla ça permet de visionner un
certain nombre de personnes sous serment
alors bon exemple d'auditionner un
ministre comme jean yves le drian ça
brise aucune difficulté parce qu'il est
coutumier du fait et qu'il vient souvent
ici maroni les personnes qui ne sont
jamais venus devant le parlement et le
fait de te prêter serment ça permet
aussi de rappeler solennellement que la
représentation nationale en particulier
le sénat peut poser des questions et que
un faux témoignage engagerait à des
poursuites pénales non moi je trouve que
c'est important ce que je veux dire sur
le fond de cette affaire c'est deux
choses d'abord je pense qu'il faut qu'on
sent absolument solidaire de l'action
menée par le gouvernement parce que il
faut le ski est menée en ce moment est
bien présent la république vis-à-vis des
etats-unis vis-à-vis de l'australie il
faut éviter les polémiques inutiles en
interne parce qu'elle ne règle rien et
il faut laisser faire notre diplomatie
notre président la république et le
gouvernement à agir et il ya un autre
sujet quel sujet de la réaction
européenne moi je suis un européen
convaincu je suis absolument scandalisé
que l'europe ait mis cinq jours à réagir
c'est un enjeu stratégique
non pas pour seulement pour l'industrie
navale française c'est un enjeu
stratégique pour la place de l'europe
dans le monde est de la france et ça que
madame von der leyen et monsieur michel
est attendu cinq jours pour dire que
l'un des états membres de l'union et
était à ce point méprisées ça me ça m'a
profondément choqué tu retiens donc
cette commission denquête n'est pas
encore actée est ce que vous vous
appartenez la majorité présidentielle
est ce que vous redoutez une éventuelle
commission d' enquête sur cette affaire
des sous marins mais absolument pas j'ai
toujours été partisan des commissions
dans lequel j'ai même été vice-président
de l'autre mais son enquête sur la sur
la pandémie donc donc c'est pour moi ça
n'est pas un sujet simplement j'ai
toujours dit et je le redis encore
qu'une bonne comme ici on enquête selon
moi se fait non pas comme l'histoire
mais un peu à froid et la faire
immédiatement à chaud alors qu'à l'heure
qu'il est on n'a que des informations
parcellaires qui vient de tous les côtés
je gordon plus en plus d'informations et
nommé le chien à jour avec des
informations des informations et tout ce
que vous voulez moi je pense que le rôle
du sénat et l'assemblée nationale si
elle le veut s'est aussi de prendre de
la hauteur du recul et d'écouté à froid
images et vous entendre alors assuré
avant d'entendre je ne suis pas la
commission des lois mais je voudrais
juste jeter a donné un petit clin d'oeil
puisqu'on parlait delà des questions des
questions au gouvernement et la première
question sera posée par richard yung mon
collègue dont ce sera la dernière
question pics ne se représente pas donc
il ne sera plus sénateur à la fin du
mois et concernera justement cette
question là donc c'est un petit clin
d'oeil je tiens à lui pas c est à dire à
tous les français écoutent et des
questions au gouvernement aujourd'hui
puisque c'est un sujet qui est abordé en
premier alors les questions d'actualité
vont commencer maintenant dans onze
minutes on voit les ministres arrivés
progressivement dans les missions qu'on
va tout de suite retrouvé quand un
chalmé qui est pas très loin de
justement de cet hémicycle quentin vous
êtes avec patrick kanner président du
groupe socialiste au sénat tout à fait
steve bonjour patrick hannais bonjour
bienvenue au micro de public sénat un
mot sur cette affaire cette crise des
sous marins on a compris que les
socialistes étaient en demande d'une
commission denquête est ce que vous avez
eu gain de cause cette demande j'ai de
bons espoirs en la matière puisque nous
avons abordé ce sujet à la conférence
des présidents dans notre jargon c'était
hier le président larcher a confirmé
qu'il faisait d'abord auditionné manière
très libre le
ministre jean yves le drian et d'autre
part ailleurs mais le principe de cette
commission denquête n'a pas été écartée
loin de là donc j'ai de bons espoirs que
la commission des affaires étrangères de
la défense se transforme en commission
denquête le moment venu les opposants à
cette commission disent qu'elles
n'auraient pas intérêt à aller en
australie aux états unis ce n'est pas
possible quel est l'apport réel d'une
commission d' enquête sur un tel sujet
déjà c'est de remarquer que l'assemblée
nationale n'a pas donné son accord pour
composer une commission d' enquête à la
demande du groupe heller c'est curieux
quand on a rien à se reprocher soyons
transparents et manifestement dans cette
affaire il y a peut être un flou et vous
connaissez la suite un mot sur la
situation sanitaire on a vu ces annonces
de gabriella talent dans les
départements où le taux d'incidence pour
être inférieur à 50 cas pour 100000
habitants il y aurait la levée du
globule à sion du port du masque dans
les écoles également de nouvelles jauges
dans les établissements qui reçoivent du
public c'est une bonne chose cette levée
de certaines mesures par département moi
je suis pour la territorialisation quand
ça permet d'assouplir finalement les
contraintes qui pèsent sur les uns et
sur les autres là où je suis plus
inquiet c'est que chacun sait
qu'aujourd'hui la population qui n'est
pas vacciné c les moins de 12 ans qu'on
va leur permettre de ne plus porter le
masque et ça je peux comprendre où est
l'intérêt pour les enseignants pour les
parents naturellement mais que tant
qu'il n'y a pas de vaccin c'est une
population à risque par rapport aux
variants multiples et variées qui peut
donc le transmettre à d'autres adultes
donc soyons prudents d'ailleurs monsieur
à thala et et 13,1 dans la matière mais
pour moi le passé ni terre est un
pis-aller il faudra modifier cela tous
les indicateurs sont à la baisse et
repasse au vert a également dit libre et
la talent est ce que ça signifie qu'une
obligation vaccinale telles que celles
que vous proposez dans un texte qui doit
venir bientôt en séance c'est toujours
d'actualité totalement je dirais même
plus que jamais parce que on arrive sur
le noyau dur de celles et ceux qui ne
veulent pas être vaccinés ou je vous
rappelle les chiffres une 9 millions de
français qui aujourd'hui devrait thaksin
et qui ne le sont pas je pense que ce
sera peut-être à l'aller peu les
populations les plus réfractaires à ce
principe vaccinale et notre proposition
et claires et simples applicables et
donc moi je souhaite vraiment que le
passé ni terre te soit pas reporté de
manière indéfinie dans le temps il faut
la vaccination obligatoire et universel
mère se moque ou patrick kanner
président du groupe socialiste et coc
n'a pas répondu à nos questions en
direct
quentin les questions d'actualité c'est
dans huit minutes à présent vous avez
entendu le président kenner sur la
vaccination obligatoire le texte s'il
arrive mi-octobre faisable pas faisable
souhaitable pas souhaitable car des non
moi je crois à la liberté la
responsabilité individuelle donc je
pense que c'est une une mauvaise mesure
qui est illusoire parce qu'elle pose des
difficultés de mise en oeuvre vous savez
je l'avais pensé au film hell ou la
cuisse où on jouerait aux
fléchettes avec des seringues pour
vérifier déjà fait tiquer quelqu'un qui
est récalcitrant vous le voyez de force
deuxièmement est ce que vous allez
dans votre vie quotidienne mise à part
la qui sont des valeurs accusations des
enfants et leur inscription à l'école
est ce que dans votre vie quotidienne on
vous a déjà demandé de présenter votre
votre carnet de vaccination moi ça m'est
arrivé la seule fois où on me l'a
demandé c'est qu'en étant officiers de
réserve on a nécessité tous les deux ans
au moment d'une visite médicale qu'on
appelle d'aptitude à la mer puisque je
suis un marin et bien haut mais on
faisait un contrôle de l'état de ma
vaccination et quand j'étais pas
vaccinés ou que mon rappel était pas
fait et bien le médecin militaire il
allait chercher le vaccin il me faisait
me le faisait mais dans la vie
quotidienne des gens l'obligation
vaccinale elle est théorique mais elle
ne donne lieu à aucun sens c'est pour ça
que je parlais tout à l'heure dû passer
les caps ou pouvant devenir passe
vaccinale qui serait le corollaire
extrait encore plus attentatoires aux
libertés mardi à rio le pass oui même
très rapidement de trois raisons la
première pour répondre à votre première
question
l'obligation de léon ce vaccin se fait
dès l'enfance donc c'est pas très
compliqué vous avez une moyens
coercitifs très simple vous n'allez pas
l'école c'est que de vacciner ça on sait
faire demander à des personnes de 85 ans
les 500 milles dont je parlais ou plus
d'être obligé de se vacciner moi je
souris déjà on a du mal à les contacter
pour leur donner l'envié de se vacciner
là on viendrait avec un pistolet un peu
comme les blocus j'avoue que l'image est
amusante je la reprends bien mais bien
vous bien volontiers troisième point qui
me paraît le plus essentiel depuis le
début de cette crise quoi qu'on en dise
le gouvernement a voulu faire confiance
aux français
sauf la première fois où on a fermé
complètement la france comme et tout le
monde était perdue on n'avait pas
d'autre choix à chaque fois après c'est
une volonté pédagogique et le pass out
here fait partie de cette pédagogie sa
éviter justement cette espèce
d'obligation coercitives
en disant aux gens que vous avez la
capacité on vous laisse le temps de vous
renseigner on vous laisse le temps de la
pédagogie on vous laisse le temps de
prendre conscience des faits qu news
qu'on passe notre temps à contredire et
c'est essentiel on a réussi on est passé
de mémoire en septembre novembre l'année
dernière à 1 une envie de vaccination de
l'ordre de 55% a aujourd'hui 80 % de
gens vaccinés ces gens là s'ils doivent
se relaxent nous le ferons sans hésiter
si on impose ça sera une ça sera
tellement difficile qu'on aura encore
plus de réfractaires et encore plus de
difficultés à vacciner les questions
d'actualité cédant très précisément cinq
minutes à présent avoir trouvé quand un
calme et quentin vous êtes toujours en
salle des conférences vous êtes avec
cédric perrin le vice président de la
commission des affaires étrangères
exactement steve bonjour cédric perrin
jette sénateurs alors un mot sur ces
auditions qui vont être menés par votre
commission de la défense et les forces
armées notamment vous aller auditionner
le ministre jean yves le drian mais
également le directeur général de la
dgse et le représentant de naval groupe
alors pourquoi vouloir auditionner ces
personnalités ont écouté la conférence
des présidents hier nous a
effectivement autorisé à à partir sur 7
sur 7 sur ces dispositions là et donc
nous allons commission commencé les
auditions rapidement le milieu des
affaires étrangères d'abord parce que je
pense que c'est celui qui a oeuvré en
plus il était le signataire de du
contrat lorsque celui ci a été avalisée
en 2016 donc il y aura évidemment un
fort intérêt à le rencontrer depuis la
diplomatie a forcément joué un rôle
majeur dans cette affaire nous avons une
ambassade à canberra qui semble-t-il n'a
pas vu vraiment les choses venir donc il
faudra aussi peut-être demander quelques
explications de ce point de vue là de la
même manière les services et bernard
emié pourront peut-être nous apporter
quelques éléments sur la chronologie des
faits sur la manière dont les choses se
sont passées depuis quelques mois
maintenant puisque certains expliquent
que il y avait des signaux d'autres nous
disent qu'il n'y avait absolument aucune
au plus aucun signal d' alerte qui qui
était visible donc voilà la commission
va pouvoir statuer enfin pouvoir en tout
cas auditionné et entendre un certain
nombre de personnes qui pourront je
pense apporter des éléments majeurs pour
cette sur cette affaire il ya 16 trois
auditions qui ont être mené rapidement
vous le disiez ensuite et bien si vous
n'avez pas les réponses à vos questions
votre commission pour évoluer en
commission denquête s'allument on a
compris qu'il y avait une prudence de la
part d elle est reçue relance à tapis
rouge et je crois qu'on n'est pas là
pour faire la chasse aux sorcières le
but c'est d'obtenir des explications sur
cette sur cette tragique affaire qui ce
qui ce qui se finit avec évidemment des
conséquences assez assez assez assez
grave pour la diplomatie pour
l'industrie pour la pause ils de
positionnement de la france dans l'est
du pacifique et pour tout une stratégie
qui avait été mise en place depuis
quelques années maintenant entre
l'australie d'un côté l'un de l'autre et
puis il faut le dire parce que c'est un
sujet majeur la nouvelle calédonie qui
va devoir voter dans quelques mois dans
quelques semaines maintenant sur son
avenir et qui est un avenir qui nous
inquiète puisque les chinois lorgneront
évidemment de très près ce ce ce
territoire pour l'instant dépendant de
la france et donc il ya beaucoup de
questionnements qui ceux qui se posent
aujourd'hui sur ce sujet
je dirais presque que l'affairé
australienne n'est qu'un petit n'est
qu'un petit n'était qu'une petite entité
de tout cela et puis il ya aussi
beaucoup d'autres contrats qui sont en
cours notamment avec la grèce sur lequel
navale groupe est en jeu et sur lequel
je pense que les américains tentent de
nous jouer un petit peu le même tour que
pour l'australie donc il ya beaucoup de
questionnements et cette commission va
pouvoir discuter de tout cela avec les
différentes personnes auditionnées et
puis si effectivement les résultats sont
pas à la hauteur de ce qu'on attend
l'article 22 de terre je crois nous
permettra de transformer la commission
en commission denquête et de pouvoir
aller plus loin dans nos investigations
est-ce que vous avez déjà une intuition
peut-être que par vos réseaux auprès de
l'armée vous avez déjà peut-être une
idée une intuition sur là où il ya eu
des trous dans la raquette pour
reprendre une expression d'un de vos
collègues notamment dans le
renseignement saoudiens des trous dans
la raquette à écouter sur le
renseignement il faudra se poser les
bonnes questions est ce que nous devons
continuer à dépendre pour nos
renseignements et pour nos informations
d'un certain nombre de pays alliés qui
s'est même alliés deviennent nos
principaux concurrents économiques sur
le terrain l'industrie de la défense
c'est une vraie question et il y en
ad'autres évidemment qui viendront se
poser à quoi bon avoir une ambassade à
l'autre bout du monde si effectivement
nous n'arrivons pas à collecter un
certain nombre d'informations mais ça
c'est facile à dire quand on était à
paris c'est un peu plus complexe quand
on est sur place donc il ya beaucoup de
sujets qui vont devoir être être pris en
compte mais j'ai bon espoir que nous
puissions trouver des réponses et je ne
suis pas de ceux qui considèrent que
naval était absolument au courant je
pense qu'il ya eu effectivement un
travail de sape en sous main qui a été
fait ce qu'elle veut dire par les
britanniques les américains et les
australiens 1 données rapides stricte et
ainsi vous voulez bien mais christophe
castaner qui parle d'une mise en scène d
opposition avec ses commission denquête
qu'est ce que vous lui répondez c'est ce
matin sur france info je me suis
questionnaire fait comme d'habitude
beaucoup de ce groupe je crois qu'il est
quand même légitime compte tenu de la
mode du montant du contrat et compte
tenu de l'émotion que ça suscite dans
notre pays
que nous puissions être informé le
parlement est là pour ça les commission
denquête sont là pour ça l'objectif
n'est pas de clouer au pilori qui que ce
soit l'objectif et essayer de comprendre
ce qui s'est passé pour essayer d'éviter
que ça se reproduise je rappelle quand
même que dans l'aisne au pacifique la
stratégie française et être clairement
appuyé sur ce partenariat avec les
australiens et qu'aujourd'hui monsieur k
sign on peut dire ce qu'il veut nous
n'attendons c'était quand même un échec
fondamental de la diplomatie française
très très rapidement une date pour
l'édition
de la semaine prochaine saurait tarder
le président va revenir demain et on
pourra ensuite je pense prendre date
rapidement merci merci beaucoup donc on
verra on suivra bien sûr à les travaux
de votre commission sur cette question
alors que vous l'entendez il va y avoir
bientôt les tambourins pour annoncer l
arrivée du président de séance c'est
l'occasion d'aller en tribune de presse
dans l'hémicycle pour retrouver jérôme
rabier bonjour jérôme dites-nous tout du
programme aujourd'hui s'il vous plaît et
bien quand on programme le sujet que
vous avez abordé avec cédric perrin
cette affaire de commandes sous marin
annulé par l'australie avec cinq
questions à ce sujet et qui viendront de
différents groupes politiques un dc au
sénat
rachid tu es mal pour les socialistes
réclamera la création d'une commission
enquête et son collègue de la manche
jean michel houlgate s'interrogera
interrogera le gouvernement sur les
conséquences pour sa ville cherbourg
dans la manche où le constructeur
naval groupe est implanté richard yung
pour la république en marche évoquera
lui les conséquences diplomatiques de
cette crise des questions aussi du
groupe communiste et les républicains
mais il n'ya pas que les sous-marins au
programme cet après midi patrice sauvé
pour le gros ce groupe centriste
alertera notamment sur la flambée des
prix de l'énergie et la réponse du
gouvernement avec ses sept chèques
énergie envoyé aux ménages les plus
modestes philippe tabarot pour les
républicains à lui une question sur la
reconnaissance pour les harkis voilà
pour le programme et c'est tout de suite
[Musique]
nous n'avons pas reçus d'observation
il y en a t'il en séance
je l'envoie pas il est donc adoptée sur
les réserves d'usagé
monsieur le premier ministre
mesdames et messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues leur religion rappelle
les questions d'actualité au
gouvernement
je rappelle que notre séance et
retransmise en direct sur public sénat
et sur notre site internet au nom du
bureau du sénat j'appelle chacun de vous
mes chers collègues a observé au cours
de nos échanges à la fois le respect des
uns et des autres celui du temps de
parole mais avant d'en venir aux
différentes questions je souhaite saluer
trois collègues représentant les
français établis hors de france qui ont
décidé de ne pas se représenter lors des
élections de dimanche prochain puisque
nous avons un calendrier particulier et
chariots qui je vais donner la parole
dans un instant claudine lepage que je
salue et qui posera sa question tout à
l'heure et notre collègue robert del
picchia
je salue leur engagement résolu à faire
entendre la voix nos compatriotes
établis hors de france sic à défendre le
rayonnement de notre pays je voulais le
dire au début de cette séance voilà
[Musique]
la parole est donc à notre collègue
richard yung pour le rassemblement des
démocrates progressistes l'indépendant
et il a deux minutes
monsieur le président messieurs les
ministres messieurs et mesdames les
ministres mes chers collègues ma
question porte sur l'annulation du
contrat de sous marins par l'australie
je pense que la france a eu raison de
montrer sa colère et de rappeler ses
ambassadeurs il y à la manière brutale
et dissimulé qui a été utilisé et il ya
le montant 52 milliards d'euros ça n'est
pas rien mais l'essentiel n'est pas là
il est dans l'attitude des états unis
qui ont contraint l'australie comme il
avait obligé les suisses à acheter leurs
chasseurs f-35 plutôt que le rafale
byden que nous avions porté aux nues au
fond fait ce que fait ou président des
états unis ce n'est d'ailleurs pas la
première fois que les états unis montre
le peu de cas qu'ils font de leurs
alliés ou de leur soi-disant alliés
rappelez-vous obama et la syrie en 2013
en l'occurrence on peut se demander si
les états unis ne se sont pas tirés une
balle dans le pied ils perdent la
confiance des grands pays européens qui
nous ont manifesté leur soutien hier aux
nations unies à new york et il gagne peu
de choses un associé mineurs le royaume
uni et un comparse l'australie qui
n'aura ces sous-marins finalement qu'en
2040 ou 2045 nous aurions pu participer
à une stratégie globale pour la région
mais y at-il encore une alliance devant
tant de duplicité mes questions sur les
suivantes la première quelles stratégies
alternatives peut-il y avoir pour la
france qui cherche à construire une
alliance indo pacifique régionales
deuxième question nous sommes nombreux à
penser que c'est l'occasion de renforcer
la politique européenne de défense
savez-vous ce qu'en pense l'allemagne en
avez vous parlé avec ou avec elle
troisièmement notre coopération
militaire avec la grande bretagne les
accords de lancaster house peut-elle
survivre à ce trafalgar
merci
de donner maintenant la parole pour vous
répondre à madame la ministre des armées
madame florence parly président mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs face aux
sénateurs permettez moi tout d'abord de
saluer votre engagement sans faille au
cours de ses 17 dernières années sur les
questions internationales européennes et
de défense alors vous le savez la france
est un pays de l'inde au pacifique nous
y avons des territoires dans les deux
océans nous et y avons des concitoyens
plus de 2 millions et nous y avons des
militaires qui sont déployés en
permanence dans cette région et puis 93%
notre zone économique exclusive et donc
nous y avons évidemment des intérêts
l'annulation de ce contrat vous l'avez
dit n'invalide pas une stratégie en ado
pacifique ce que nous proposons aux
acteurs de la région c'est une stratégie
qui est en quelque sorte une alternative
face au modèle chinois et dont
l'objectif est clair refusé d'être
l'otage de la rivalité entre la chine et
les états unis notre stratégie intègre à
la fois la dimension environnementale
sécuritaire commerciale et la liberté de
navigation dans cet espace maritime où
transitent 60% de la richesse mondiale
alors aujourd'hui nous ne sommes pas
seuls monsieur le sénateur en radon en
indo pacifique
nous y avons des partenaires importants
l'inde le japon la malaisie ou encore
l'indonésie et pour la première fois de
son histoire l'europe s'est emparé de
cette question en se dotant d'une
stratégie indo pacifique européenne
écrite à 27 mais c'est une première et
cette stratégie trouvera un écho dans la
boussole stratégique ce premier livre
blanc de la défense européenne qui sera
l'une des priorités de la présidence
française de l'union européenne dans
quelques mois ainsi donc monsieur le
sénateur non seulement
nous affirmons non seulement la
nécessité pour l'europe de protéger son
espace propre mais aussi d'être capable
de se projeter au-delà des frontières de
l'union européenne
chaque fois et partout où ses intérêts
sont en jeu et je pense que c'est une
bonne nouvelle pour les français et les
européens merci
et donner la parole maintenant notre
collègue rachid tu es mal pour le groupe
socialiste écologique et red bull
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président monsieur prémices
mes chers collègues jamais depuis
l'avènement la 5ème public la france n'a
connu une telle humiliation oui mais ce
premier test la france est humiliée bien
sûr nous condamnons comme vous monsieur
près ministre les agissements de nos
alliés américains britanniques et
australiens mais force est de constater
que cette affaire dit des sous marins
australiens en dit long sur votre
gouvernance est votre bilan le contrat
du siècle évaporé la place de la france
bazzo nadeau pacifique écarté et la
place de la france sur les chaînes
nationales et rabaissé et je crois que
vous devez la transparence et la vérité
aux français vous la devez également à
la représentation nationale donc je
pense qu'il est important de répondre à
des questions simples d'abord comment
comprendre que ni l'elysée ni matignon
ni le quai ils nos ambassades nos
services n'ont vu sur entendu ce qui se
tramait avec la rupture d'un contrat est
une nouvelle alliance au cuss
quel ministre croire monsieur
prémunissent quand nous avons deux
versions différentes entre les ministres
français et les ministres australiens
comment comprendre l'avenir dorénavant
après les propos de compliquer sur
l'otan et la place de la france dans
l'otan et quelle place pour la défense
au niveau européen et enfin monsieur le
premier ministre
quel avenir de pour nos intérêts et nos
français la liste a rappelé plus de 2
millions je pense à ma nouvelle
calédonie dans un espace où la chine sam
de plus en plus je vous remercie on vous
répond de la parole était valable amélie
for me
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs sur le sénateur
permettez-moi d'être étonné pour ne pas
dire choquée d'entendre dans cet
hémicycle un responsable et un
représentant de la nation donner le
sentiment qu'au fond ce qui arrive à la
france est plutôt un motif d'
instrumentalisation du débat politique
interne plutôt que plutôt que de vue
plutôt que monsieur le sénateur de
considérer que c'est la france sa place
dans le monde et ses relations avec ses
partenaires ses alliés au premier rang
desquels les états unis qui est en débat
c'est une question sérieuse qui me
paraît devoir nécessité la mobilisation
de chacun
les français auront l'occasion de
s'exprimer sur les débats de politique
intérieure dans quelques mois alors si
vous le voulez bien revendre en un an à
la sphère qui nous intéresse cette
affaire vous le savez c'est c'est une
rupture de confiance parce que rompre un
contrat ce n'est pas voir une la
confiance c'est rodez vous connaissez le
sens des mots la rupture c'est brutal et
ça ne s'anticipe pas et c'est ce qui
s'est passé monsieur le sénateur car
lorsque jean yves le drian et moi même
nous avons tenu avec nos homologues
australiens le 30 août une réunion qu'on
appelle le 2 + 2 qui sont des réunions
que l'on tient avec des partenaires
stratégiques comme l'australie et que
lors de cette réunion il a été confirmé
l'importance majeure de ce contrat de
sous marins vous pouvez convenir
monsieur sénateurs qu'il s'agit d'une
forme de duplicité et lorsque le premier
ministre australien écrite au président
de la république le 15 septembre au
moment où l'annoncé faite et qu'il dit
que le programme de sous-marins classe
attaque et le meilleur sous marins de
classe océanique dans le monde vous
comprendrez bien monsieur le sénateur
qu' on ne peut pas à réécrire l'histoire
a posteriori ou alors évidemment on
s'érige en juge ou en procureur ce que
dont je comprends d'ailleurs que c'est
l'intention du sénat et vous aurez
puisque
[Musique]
suivez les provocations dont pas une
utilité absolue pour éclairer le débat
et comme vous le savez mesdames et
messieurs le sénateur c'est toujours
avec plaisir que je me plie aux
commissions aux questions du sénat donc
je le ferai
je le ferai comme je les ai toujours
fait
fait mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
mais je pense que dans cette affaire
nationale ne ferait pas de mal monsieur
rachid et l
[Musique]
madame la ministre
malheureusement encore une fois votre
réponse est à côté comment dire
aujourd'hui que quand le parlement et le
sénat fait simplement son travail qui
est le contrôle nous serions dans une
logique de procureur nous pourrons
sablon des questions légitimes dès le 2
juin dernier un article dans un grand
journal australien évoqué la difficulté
sur ce contrat là vous n'avez rien dire
et fait ce que je note c'est que la
gesticulation diplomatique qui est fait
par votre gouvernement n'est pas à la
hauteur d'un pays comme la france et
c'est pour cela nous demandons encore
aujourd'hui plus que jamais une
commission d'enquêté sénatoriale pour
que la vérité soit faite et que
l'enseignement soit tiré je vous
remercie
[Musique]
la parole est à peu près collègues et
rigole pour le groupe du rassemblement
démocratique et social européen
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre la pratique sportive a été
considérablement affaiblie depuis le
début de la crise sanitaire les clubs
sportifs amateurs sont à la peine
constatant une chute nombre des
licenciés de bénévoles qui mettent en
péril leur financer l'organisation des
compétitions
la baisse de l'activité physique a été
qualifié de bombe à retardement
sanitaire dans un rapport de l'assemblée
si la réponse du gouvernement par
l'intermédiaire du passeport apparaît
comme une initiative intéressante à la
cunette de 50 euros sur l'adhésion une
association sportive pour les 6-17 ans
sous certaines conditions l' enveloppe
dédiée de 100 millions d'euros semble
largement insuffisante pour toucher les
plus de 5 millions de jeunes concernés
d'autant plus que les débuts du
passeport sont et c'est un euphémisme
particulièrement timide si certains
attendent de savoir en fonction de
l'évolution de la situation sanitaire si
les compétitions auront bien lieu cette
année d'autres se heurte aux difficultés
des associations dans la mise en place
de la mesure l' agence nationale du
sport demande en effet au club la
création d'un compte aso pour le
remboursement des 50 euros qui ne sont
pas demandées aux bénéficiaires du
passeport ils sont aujourd'hui que 40
mille club sur 180 milles en activité à
avoir créé ce compte et pour cause
certains salariés est en manque de
bénévoles ne peuvent tout simplement pas
le faire enfin dans un pays où 17% de la
population est touchée par l'électro
nisme imposer la création d'un compte
internet en nécessairement la mesure
moins populaire le décret publié le 10
septembre en est à ses tout débuts mais
c'est maintenant que se joue la saison
c'est maintenant que se constituent les
équipes et les associations enfin
l'occasion de sortir la tête de l'eau je
présenterai le 14 octobre avec mes
collègues du groupe rds une proposition
de loi visant à créer une aide
supplémentaire sur les associations et
sur les adhésions aux associations
sportives culturelles
et récréatives et a relevé la réduction
d'impôt en vigueur sur les dons de ces
associations aussi madame la ministre
quelles mesures complémentaires et aides
aux associations le gouvernement
compte-t-il engagé pour conforter des
bénévoles et le sport amateur en général
je vous remercie
pour vous répondre la parole est comme
adam la milice de l'ailier chargé des
sports madame rachid est à nous
monsieur le président monsieur le
sénateur eric gold comme vous l'avez dit
le passeport est une véritable
allocations de rentrée sportive dotée de
100 millions d'euros et j'ai l'honneur
d'annoncer la reconduction au plf 2022
de cette mesure c'est une grande et
belle avancée qui illustre l'engagement
de notre gouvernement pour démocratiser
la pratique sportive en france cette
réduction de 50 euros que vous avez
évoqué je vous rassure sur l'adhésion
sportive pour un jeune sur deux incite
aujourd'hui fortement les enfants et les
jeunes à s'inscrire en club c'est à dire
à une activité encadrée sécurisé
essentielles vous l'avez dit aussi pour
la santé le bien-être de nos jeunes
5,4 millions de jeunes de 6 à 17 ans
sont concernés et nous recevons
aujourd'hui monsieur le sénateur les
inscriptions de 15 mille enfants
directement en ligne la démarche est
simple pour créer le comtat sans
quelques clics ognier nous travaillons
d'ailleurs avec des tiers payeurs qui
viennent du mouvement sportif et qui
sont là pour aider et accompagner les
associations dont les bénévoles pourrait
être aujourd'hui débordé c'est le cas
puisque les inscriptions marche bien
j'ai moi-même été sur le terrain comme
vous dans différentes dans différents
forums des associations et j'ai pu
constater que les inscrits reviennent
aujourd'hui est que cette mesure va être
pleinement utilisés
je tiens à rappeler que le gouvernement
vous m'avez demandé ce que nous avons
fait pour le sport aujourd'hui nous
sommes intervenus à hauteur de 6,5
milliards d'euros pour le sport français
dans toutes ses dimensions amateurs
professionnels
salle de sport du secteur commercial
c'est une aide unique aujourd'hui pour
le secteur sportif sachez aussi que mon
ministère soutient la fondation du sport
français dans le cadre de l'opération
solidaire soutient ton club et que une
plate forme de mécénat permet de
défiscaliser les dons particuliers des
entreprises au club sport tif et nous
accordons à cette défiscalisation
évidemment une importance très forte
parce que nous comptons sur le bc
mécénat pour soutenir effectivement le
mouvement sportif nous avons lancé une
communication au mois de septembre pour
surfer aussi sur les bons résultats des
jeux olympiques et paralympiques pour
soutenir la pratique sportive dans
toutes ses dimensions à tous les âges et
à tous les niveaux de pratique une
campagne de communication qui a été
relayé aussi bien par le mouvement
contre lui par les structures
commerciales et les clubs professionnels
de sport merci merci madame min la
parole est maintenant notre collègue
daniel chalon pour le groupe écologie
solidarité territoire vous avez la
parole
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre il y a quelques jours au sommet
mondial de la biodiversité à marseille
le président de la république déclarait
dans un beau discours sa détermination à
porter haut et fort les enjeux de la
biodiversité
et voilà que nous apprenons que le
gouvernement s'apprête à ré-autoriser
des pratiques de chasse récemment
interdite avec le piégeage traditionnel
de plus de cent mille oiseaux sauvages
des espèces en déclin
ceci alors que le conseil d'état et la
cour de justice européenne ont récemment
déclaré ces pratiques illégales et alors
que la france a perdu rappelons le près
du tiers de ces oiseaux depuis le début
du xxième siècle ou ne serais pas
surpris madame la ministre vien nous
apparaît inimaginable de tolérer à
nouveau demain c'est chasse non
sélective l'espagne a déjà été condamnée
par l'union européenne sur ce fondement
certains prétendent que défendre la
chasse c'est défendre la ruralité
c'est défendre les traditions
non non madame la musique non mes chers
collègues le monde rural ne sera pas
menacé par l'interdiction de pratique
cruelle et dépasser pratique qui
s'exerce sur des populations en déclin
la majorité des ruraux sont d'ailleurs
opposés à ces pratiques de chasse les
chiffres sont têtus seuls 26% des ruraux
sont adorables à chaque telle qu'elle
est pratiquée et précisons également que
70% des chasseurs sont des urbains oui
nous appelons au respect de la ruralité
une réalité bienveillante vivante et
respectueuse de toutes et tous respectez
la ruralité c'est d'abord cessé de se
dire un modèle libéral qui metropolis la
france en détruisant les emplois ruraux
c'est ces cétacés de cette agriculture
intensive qui met à mal trop de paysans
et de paysages c'est arrêter de détruire
les services publics c'est aussi pouvoir
se promener tranquillement le dimanche
en forêt ou sur des chantiers des
chemins ruraux en paix
vos mesures clientélistes n'ont rien à
voir avec la défense de la ruralité
madame liste quand allez vous prendre en
compte ces territoires délaissés merci
pour vous répondre la parole et à madame
la secrétaire d'état chargé de la
biodiversité
mme adama bâ vous avez la parole merci
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur salmon sur ce sujet de la
chasse nous cherchons et en
responsabilité je crois d'abord à
apaiser ce débat puisqu'il est évident
que personne ne souhaite voir
s'installer cette agressivité et cette
tension entre un monde présumé urbain et
un monde rural qui serait soit disant
incapable de se comprendre et de
s'entendre nous avons sur ce sujet de la
chasse des solutions pragmatiques a
dessiné une protection d'abord de la
biodiversité vous le savez nous y
travaillons dans le cadre de la gestion
adaptative avec cette notion
effectivement de sélectivité qui est
extrêmement importante pour le bon état
des populations avec également un
contexte et des pratiques qui sont
anciennes et qui forme et vous le savez
une forme de patrimoine un patrimoine
culturel et si vous connaissez bien la
ruralité comme moi vous vous le savez
nous avons donc en regard de cela des
questions juridiques sommes-nous ou non
dans le cadre européen
et effectivement nous devons nous nous
en assurer sur la préservation des
oiseaux notamment et dans la dans le
cadre de la directive du même nom le
conseil d'état il a pris une décision
sur la forme sur la construction de ces
arrêtés et non pas sur le fond et nous
avons souhaité effectivement soumettre à
nouveau s'est arrêté pour vérifier les
fondements et en fin de compte clore ce
débat pour ce qui est du cadre
législatif et de l'autorisation de ses
différentes pratiques je précise bien
différent puisqu'il s'agit de pratiques
différentes et on le verra en termes de
sélectivité cela effectivement son
importance avec également donc sur ces
bases juridiques cette nécessité
d'observer ce qui a déjà été mis en
oeuvre dans le cadre de certaines
pratiques et certaines chasses qui
répond à vos questions nous avons arrêté
la chasse à la glu nous avons également
suspendu les chasses de la barge à queue
noire aux courlis cendré ou au grand
écran donc vous savez ces éléments ils
ont été observés et nous nous inscrivons
dans ce cadre la lignée là un cadre
législatif européen sur la sélectivité
un bon état des populations évidemment
la sécurité et dans les pratiques et la
formation à la chasse avec des débats
des questions sociétales qui peuvent
interroger sur le bien être animal et je
serai devant cette assemblée dans
quelques jours pour pour un débattre
concernant la faune sauvage nous avons
en tout cas je crois au delà de la
démocratisation de certaines pratiques
assurer ce cadre de sécurité et nous
sommes très attachés au cadre européen
et à la conservation de ces populations
merci mme hammiche troc nous donne la
parole à deux collègues colette mélot
pour le groupe les indépendants
république et territoires
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre de l'éducation nationale mes
chers collègues si la question n'est pas
nouvelle la crise sanitaire a aggravé la
pénurie d'infirmiers scolaire dans les
établissements
la profession souffrait déjà avant la
crise d'un manque d'attractivité et de
mauvaises conditions de travail en 2018
ont dénombré un infirmier pour 1300
élèves désormais avec un infirmier pour
1800 élèves en seine saint denis il est
impossible de travailler correctement
d'autant plus que la charge de travail
s'est considérablement accrue avec la
mise en place des mesures sanitaires et
l'augmentation importante des besoins
d'accompagnement des élèves largement
affecté par la crise
autre facteur aggravant leur
rémunération largement inférieures à
celles proposées par les établissements
de santé la situation est telle que 66%
des infirmiers scolaires envisage de
changer de métier et nous savons que
nombre d'entre eux ont déjà franchi le
pas accentuant la charge de ceux qui
restent faute de remplaçant monsieur le
ministre la situation n'est plus tenable
vous connaissez le rôle fondamental des
et firent des infirmiers de l'éducation
nationale
outre leur rôle de soignant ils sont le
premier le dernier rempart contre le
décrochage scolaire
la dépression la maltraitance familiale
ou le harcèlement leur mission de
prévention de ces risques d' écoute de
détection des situations d'urgence et
d'accompagnement sont indispensables au
bon fonctionnement de l'enseignement
nous ne pouvons faire l'économie d'une
juste revalorisation de la profession au
delà de celles annoncées dans le cadre
du grenelle de l'éducation qui va dans
le bon sens cela passe bien entendu par
une hausse des salaires mais aussi par
une formation adaptée et éventuellement
une territorialisation de leur
recrutement dans le cadre d'une
réorganisation globale de la santé
scolaire l'égalité d'accès à la santé
des élèves est une composante
essentielle de l'égalité des chances
pourriez-vous préciser monsieur le
ministre les actions que le gouvernement
souhaite mettre en place pour lutter
contre la pénurie d'infirmiers de
l'éducation nationale pour vous répondre
la parole et au ministre de l'éducation
nationale de la jeunesse et des sports
monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice colette mélot je vous remercie
pour cette question qui permet de mettre
l'accent sur les infirmiers et les
infirmières scolaires qui comme vous
l'avez très bien dit représente un corps
est essentielle pour l'éducation
nationale leur rôle au quotidien vous
l'avez rappelé est extrêmement important
et a été encore plus important dans la
période que nous vivons depuis 18 mois
parce que ces infirmières j'utiliserai
le féminin parce que la plupart du temps
ce sont des femmes les infirmières et
bien au quotidien non seulement font
d'eux des opérations de santé mais en
réalité ont un rôle beaucoup plus large
que l'on peut qualifier d' éducatif
c'est pourquoi lorsqu'on parle des
infirmières scolaires on doit parler
d'ailleurs de manière systémique dans
leurs relations avec l'ensemble des
acteurs de l'établissement y compris
auprès du chef d'établissement car
souvent contre le harcèlement contre les
difficultés de tous ordres que
rencontrent les enfants et les
adolescents elles sont là nous en avons
donc besoin et nous avons besoin du
travail dgt équipe qui va avec cela
alors oui il faut qu'elle soit
revalorisé ne faisons faisons un tableau
juste il ya une stabilité en réalité du
nombre d'infirmières en france scolaire
depuis 2018 le nombre de lots les deux
lauréats au concours est resté à peu
près le même elles sont 8024 au moment
où je vous parle il serait bon qu'elles
soient un peu plus nombreuses et c'est
pourquoi nous ouvrons des postes au
concours l'année prochaine en grand
nombre notre objectif c'est aussi de les
revaloriser là aussi je suis évidemment
en complète accord avec vous d'abord
dans le cadre du grenelle de l'éducation
je vous remercie de l'avoir rappelé
puisque c'est une revalorisation de 400
euros annuels qui a déjà commencé pour
l'année 2000 21 et bien entendu nous
continuons nous continuerons à aller de
l'avant dans le cadre du grenelle de
l'éducation et de revalorisation dans
l'éducation nationale et puis il y à
l'adéquation avec les autres mesures
prises pour les autres personnels de
santé dans le reste de la société et
vous avez raison il ya un risque de
distorsion si le ségur de la santé se
traduit par des revalorisations préseau
d'infirmières et pas pour l'éducation
nationale avec un risque de fuite un
endroit vers l'autre c'est pourquoi avec
amélie de montchalin nous avons
travaillé parce que cette revalorisation
est lieu dans ce cadre aussi et donc je
peux vous le dire avec un millier de
montchanin que en effet nous préparons
pour 2022 le fait qu'elle soit
revalorisé dans le contexte du ségur de
la santé je vous remercie
merci la parole est maintenant notre
collègue gérard longuet pour le groupe
l'est républicain
oui merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les ministres et
surtout mes chers collègues ma question
s'adressait à bruno le maire pourquoi
parce que de tous les membres de ce
gouvernement il est sans doute celui qui
s'est expliqué avec le plus de clarté en
faveur de l'électronucléaire
considérant comme nous le considérons
très largement au groupe auquel
j'appartiens que le nucléaire n'est pas
simplement un complément mais surtout
une condition du de la décarbonation de
notre énergie européenne alors madame le
ministre
vous avez en charge l'industrie c'est
formidable parce que le nucléaire est
pour notre industrie un atout
fantastique la france va présider
l'union européenne pendant six mois
évidemment ma question tourne autour de
cette idée simple allez vous convaincre
nos partenaires que dans une situation
d'extrême urgence ou la transition
énergétique est un devoir absolu
il faut fixer une priorité qui est 2
décarbonés et non pas de s'amuser à tout
prix à verdir avec des modes qui sont
aussi aléatoire qu'intermittent ans ou
qui appellent pour cette raison ada
consommation de gaz et après tout quand
on ne veut pas nucléaire on accepte
north stream mais on choisit 500 grammes
de co2 au kilomètre heure là où le
nucléaire ont produit 12 or notre
nucléaire français a besoin d'argent et
lorsque le commissaire johannes hahn
explique très clairement que les
obligations vertes ne seront pas
ouvertes c'est le cas de le dire au
nucléaire mais envisageable pour le gaz
on est terrassé par autant de courte vue
autant d'idéologie autant de sectarisme
comment allez-vous utiliser au moins les
trois premiers mois de votre présidence
et ça vous permettra peut-être de tenir
six mois merci beaucoup
pour vous répondre
la parole est à la ministre déléguée
changer la donne pas des rues la chine
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
ministre longuet merci de dire avec
beaucoup de clarté que le nucléaire est
une énergie décarbonée que c'est une
énergie qui est stable et non aléatoire
et que en plus en france elle représente
une de nos filières d'excellence nous
avons deux cent vingt mille
professionnels et donc dans ce moment
d'urgence climatique nous aurions tort
de ne pas appuyer nous appuyer sur cette
énergie et c'est clairement la stratégie
que nous poursuivons vous l'avez demain
d'ailleurs mentionné bruno le maire
était particulièrement clair le
président de la république aussi le
premier ministre aussi pas plus tard que
lundi et je crois que je porte une
parole commune avec tout le monde
s'agissant la question que vous posez je
crois qu'il faut faire la distinction
effectivement entre les missions des
greens bande donc des obligations vertes
qui a une définition qui est
effectivement englobe uniquement les
renouvelables et de très petites
extensions sur des usages du gaz et qui
est une définition ancienne qui n'a pas
de nouveautés je dirais et qui finance
techniquement une partie du plan de
relance est le vrai combat que nous
menons de la taxonomie alors comme vous
le savez ma collègue émilie de montchat
la meule rappelé lors des green deal
nous avions insérer le nucléaire comme
étant un élément de réponse au défi
climatique et cela avait été une
négociation portait fortement un
président de la république
nous allons continuer avec la taxonomie
je crois que nous avons le soutien du
commissaire breton qui a une vision
industrielle pour l'europe qui a une
vision aussi basée sur des faits pas sûr
de la démagogie ou des rêves et c'est en
ce sens aussi que nous investissons dès
maintenant dans le plan de relance dans
la filière nucléaire puisque nous avons
une enveloppe spécifique de 500 millions
d'euros c'est le combat qu tôt porteront
aussi dans la paix fut sur différents
éléments vous savez que j'aurai
l'honneur de présider le conseil
compétitivité nous avons des textes qui
au delà de la taxonomie dont nous
espérons avoir l'aboutissement avant
notre présidence qui porteront sur le
green deal est là encore priorité à la
neutralité technologique a une vision
industrielle qui englobe tous les effets
pour l'emploi et pour la décarbonation
et à une accélération de la
décarbonation parce que c'est l'urgence
du moment pour sauver notre industrie et
sauver nos emplois et notre climat merci
le même liste
la parole est à notre collègue patrick
chauvet pour le groupe de l'union
centriste
mais monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues les questions se suivent comme
mon collègue gérard longuet ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'économie et des finances les prix du
gaz de l'électricité et du pétrole ne
cesse de battre des records le gaz s'est
renchéri de 300% et l'électricité de 97
% depuis le début de l'année et depuis
une semaine l'essence a augmenté de 15%
or cette flambée promet d'être durables
les prix du gaz et de l'électricité sont
au sommet alors que la saison froide n'a
pas commencé en cause la faiblesse des
stocks européens et la hausse du prix du
co2
dans ces conditions les experts
n'attendent pas de baisse des prix de
l'énergie ce qui serait catastrophique
pour les entreprises d'abord elles ont
déjà commencé à en souffrir pour les
ménages ensuite dans la facture
énergétique devrait bondir de 10% en
début de l'année prochaine
enfin pour l'ensemble de l'économie car
cette flambée pourrait être responsable
d'un demi point d'inflation dans la zone
euro en fin d'année en conséquence le
chèque énergie réactivée par le
gouvernement n'est pas à la mesure du
problème
quelle est la stratégie énergétique de
la france quel levier notamment fiscaux
entendez vous actionnez pour éviter le
pire et enfin allez vous relancez le nu
et je vous remercie merci pour vous
répondre la parole est à la secrétaire
d'état chargé de la biodiversité
adam bérenger rabat vous avez la parole
madame la ministre
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
les sénateurs monsieur le sénateur
chauvet la hausse des prix de
l'électricité
voilà merci la hausse des prix de
l'électricité sur les marchés européens
sont une préoccupation forte du
gouvernement vous le savez du fait
notamment de son impact vous l'avez dit
sur les sur les consommateurs elle est
liée à l'augmentation des prix des
combustibles sur ces marchés
internationaux et contrairement à
d'autres pays d'europe comme l'espagne
par exemple où beaucoup de paris sont
indexés sur les cotations journalière
est donc très exposé à la hausse des
marchés les ménages français sont par
construction plus protégé puisque face à
cette volatilité des marchés nous avons
des coûts d'approvisionnement qui sont
pris en compte dans les tarifs
réglementés de vente qui comprennent une
part versée à la reine ce dispositif
d'accès à l'électricité nucléaire
historique donc crier fixe les
consommateurs bénéficient donc de la
compétitivité de la stabilité des coûts
du nucléaire et puis les tarifs
réglementés comprennent aussi une part
d'approvisionnement au marché en partie
glisser sur 24 mois ce qui est un autre
facteur de stabilité et nombre d'offres
de marché sont déterminés ainsi au
regard des tarifs réglementés seulement
l'augmentation des prix
d'approvisionnement en électricité sur
la marché aura effectivement un impact
sur les coûts qui est pris en compte
dans les tarifs et là il reviendra à la
creuse de déterminer cette évolution est
proposé une évolution du tarif
réglementé au premier semestre 2022 nous
sommes donc effectivement évidemment
très soucieux du pouvoir d'achat des
français donc des dispositifs à mettre
en place en réponse à cette augmentation
avec un dispositif que vous avez cité le
chèque énergie dont il convient quand
même de rappeler qu'en 2021 ce sont 5 à
5,8 millions de ménages vont bénéficier
d'un montant moyen de 150 euros et un
chèque exceptionnelle de 100 euros sera
adressée en décembre aux cinq ans aux
5,8 millions de bénéficiaires comme une
aide exceptionnelle dans ce contexte et
puis effectivement des questions ont été
posées par certains sur les traitements
de la reine avec un relèvement qui
permettrait certes d'augmenter sa
pondération dans le calcul des tarifs
réglementés en 2022 mais une décision
unilatérale présenterait également des
risques juridiques qui sont trop
importants à court terme et qui rendrait
cette décision inopérantes le
gouvernement considère donc un
relèvement du plafond de la reine n'est
pas une solution possible nous étudions
des solutions complémentaires pour
limiter tout en restant dans le cadre
légal cette hausse des prix de
l'électricité
d'autres mesures structurelles en sont
mises en place on le savait la prime
rénove les certificats d'énergie et le
projet de budget 2010 22 nous permettra
de les étudier jour merci merci monsieur
sauver
merci madame la ministre en charge de la
biodiversité et merci de relayer à
monsieur le ministre des finances
si j'ai bien compris soit on continue
comme ça et on fait du chèque énergie
soit s'intéressent vraiment au coeur du
problème qui est notre sécurité
d'approvisionnement
[Applaudissements]
je donnais réparant le président pierre
laurent pour le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen et que le juge avait
la parole monsieur le président merci
monsieur le président madame la ministre
coup dans le dos
duplicité mensonges trahisons rupture
majeure de confiance les mots que le
gouvernement employés et que vous venez
de reprendre depuis la rupture du
contrat des sous marins sont des mots
très durs
si les mots ont un sens
des conséquences majeures doivent donc
être tirée ma question est donc simple
madame la ministre
quelles conséquences allez vous tirer de
cette situation la décision américaine
de nous imposer un tel camouflet est
lourde de signification politique
les etats unis ont choisi de faire de la
zone indo pacifique une zone de
confrontation directe y compris sur le
terrain militaire avec la chine et ils
ne toléreront leurs alliés que sur leurs
commandements et à leur seul profit
les etats unis sont prêts pour cela à
faire une escalade dans le surarmement
de la région
quitte à disséminer des technologies
militaires nucléaires utilisant de
l'uranium enrichi au mépris des
engagements de non prolifération
est en forme il on voit par la même
occasion à leurs alliés de l'otan
message d'alignement brutale qui visent
directement quiconque en europe
envisagerait de s'écarter du rau
madame la ministre est ce l'intérêt de
la france et de l'europe de continuer à
s'aligner derrière de tels projets est
ce l'intérêt de la france de continuer à
participer au commandement militaire
intégré de l'otan dont les états unis
viennent de nous dire qu'ils veulent
être les seuls patrons est ce l'intérêt
de la france de tourner tout son
industrie militaire vers la course à
l'exportation d'armes pour quémander
notre part du gâteau auprès des
américains est ce l'intérêt de la france
et des européens de couvrir après à une
europe de la défense
défini comme pilier européen de l'otan
dans ces conditions un pilier auquel on
dénierait donc toute autonomie
stratégique
maîtrisé par les européens eux mêmes
n'est ce pas le moment ou jamais de
définir autrement notre avenir
stratégique êtes vous prêt à ouvrir sans
tabou tous ces débats on vous répondra
parallèle que la milice désormais
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur il est vrai que ces derniers
mois la vie n'est pas un long fleuve
tranquille à l'otan je pense évidemment
à l'aventurisme turc en méditerranée ou
bien au retrait précipité en afghanistan
de façon non concertée dont nous avons
vu les dramatiques conséquences
l'attitude des états unis à l'égard du
programme des sous-marins évoqué il y à
quelques minutes est une nouvelle
illustration du constat que nous faisons
depuis des mois
c'est qu'aujourd'hui le dialogue
politique est inexistant au sein de
l'alliance atlantique
alors quelles conséquences faut-il en
tirer
est ce que cela vaut de claquer la porte
de l'otan je ne le crois pas et je
voudrais revenir sur quelques points le
premier vous avez raison l'alliance
atlantique a un coeur de métier ce coeur
de métier c'est la défense collective de
l'europe c'est l'article 5 les etats
unis jouent un rôle essentiel
mais la france aussi y joue son rôle en
témoignant de sa solidarité par exemple
auprès des états baltes dans le cadre
d'opérations de présence de l'otan mais
la raison d'être de l'otan ce n'est pas
la confrontation avec la chine la raison
d'être de l'otan c'est la sécurité
transatlantique et c'est ce que nous
devons rappeler aux états unis c'est
donc dans cette logique que les alliés
ont décidé à notre initiative ainsi qu'à
celle de l'allemagne
d'engager une révision du concept
stratégique de l'alliance ce travail
nous permettra de clarifier et c'est
nécessaire
ce concept stratégique dans la
perspective du prochain sommet de madrid
et surtout de le faire en cohérence avec
la boussole stratégique travail lancé
par les européens
pour renforcer l'europe de la défense
pour terminer monsieur le sénateur est
rallié ce n'est pas être l'otage des
intérêts de l'autre
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à notre collègue dominique
de legge pour le groupe l'est
républicain
monsieur le président sur le premier
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues
les différentes auditions que nous
allons avoir autour
du contrat australien nous permettront
je l'espère du voit un peu plus clair
mais vous le savez aussi bien que moi
lorsqu'il s'agit de contrats de ce type
c'est pas simplement des matériels que
nous vendons c'est un environnement
géopolitique
et la france dans le pacifique c'est la
nouvelle calédonie alors vous devrez
vous me dire si vous ne pensez pas
que l'absence de position de
gouvernement lors des différents
référendum sur le maintien de la
nouvelle-calédonie dans le périmètre de
la république n'a pas contribué à ce
résultat car nous allier ont sans doute
besoin de s'assurer de la pérennité de
la france dans ce secteur
[Applaudissements]
on va répondre la parole et à monsieur
sébastien le corps du ministre en charge
des outre-mer merci monsieur le
président du sénat mesdames messieurs
les sénateurs l'état est neutre pour
organiser le scrutin le gouvernement de
la république lui peut témoigner d'une
orientation d'une préférence et le
président de la république en tant que
chef de l'état l'a fait lors de son
discours à nouméa devant le théâtre de
nouméa le premier ministre jean castex
ici présent l'a fait devant votre haute
assemblée dès les premières semaines de
sa prise de fonction dont je pense que
sur les orientations du gouvernement de
la république en nouvelle-calédonie les
choses sont connues la vraie question
c'est cette affaire dite des sous-marins
qu'est-ce qu'elle vient rappeler dans
cette zone désormais très complexe dans
le pacifique sud la première des choses
évidemment c'est que la relation entre
la nouvelle calédonie l'australie sont
des relations de fait au quotidien des
évacuations sanitaires des échanges de
marchandises des échanges universitaires
et pardon monsieur le sénateur mais la
question du nickel et de la mine dont on
voit très bien que l'interdépendance
entre l'australie nouvelle calédonie
sont tout à fait établi la deuxième des
choses c'est que le processus ainsi su
institutionnel que vous avez rappelé il
est ancien il est profondément désormais
déconnectées du contexte géopolitique je
vous renvoie aux déclarations du leader
indépendantiste jean-marie tjibaou en
1985 lorsqu'il indiquait on ceux
d'ailleurs une interview très construite
intéressante qu'au fond la nouvelle
calédonie n'avait pas d'ennemis que la
zone était calme et que kanaky
indépendante n'aurait pas besoin d'armée
la guerre froide au fond n'a eu que très
peu d'impact sur les accords de matignon
dit no 88 le contexte qui a présidé aux
accords de nouméa en 98 au fond peu d'
ingérence étrangère donc on le voit bien
la vraie question c'est que cette
balance entre la chine d'un côté et
l'occident tout entier de l'autre côté a
traversé profondément la société
calédonienne le vrai question maintenant
elle se pose le 12 décembre prochain
c est ce que les calédoniens affronte
cette question dans la république ou
est-ce qu'il affronte seul et ça pour le
plus c'est la parole que la france a
donné d'en mener ce processus jusqu'à
son terme ça a été la parole
de nicolas sarkozy à paroles de jacques
chirac la parole de françois hollande
c'est la parole des manuels macron et
c'est la parole de la france qui est en
jeu de respecter cette parole est de
définir un destin pour la nouvelle
calédonie le 13 décembre au matin en
faisant un jeu monsieur le sénateur que
la campagne présidentielle ne viennent
pas politiser excessivement un dossier
très complexe c'est un voeu que je forme
je pense que le sénat le sénat aura à
coeur de converger vers ce voeu merci je
sais de lège
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le ministre veut pour veut gens
forment un
c'est que le président de la république
le premier ministre et vous même soyez
plus clair sur ce sujet car excusez moi
de vous le dire
mais pourtant la chose est sérieux mais
vous vous défie g vous vous défilez
moins bien que nos sous marins dans
cette affaire
je suis désolé de vous le dire comme ça
mes amis mais c'est un peu trop facile
de donner des leçons de morale en
déclarant que l'otan est en situation de
mort cérébrale
c'est un peu plus compliqué
de rap et dans le pacifique notre
position y compris en nouvelle calédonie
et en matière de politique intérieure
madame la ministre
monsieur le premier ministre vous avez
refusé le débat sur la lpm et vous savez
très bien que la lpm c'est le coeur du
sujet c'est à dire nos capacités
opérationnelles
c'est-à-dire
notre industrie et bien je constate que
le sénat avait raison de demander cette
révision de la lpm ça nous aurait permis
d'avoir un débat au fond car vous êtes
en train de réussir cette performance
met en veilleuse ur du en même temps en
même temps augmenter les crédits de la
défense et en même temps diminué nos
capacités opérationnelles et affaiblir
notre industrie
merci
[Applaudissements]
je donne la parole à madame claudine
lepage pour le groupe socialiste
écologistes et républicains
c'est sa dernière prise de parole dans
notre habib sy
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse au ministre de l'éducation
nationale de la jeunesse et des sports
monsieur le ministre depuis le début de
la rentrée scolaire des collégiens tenez
en 2010 sont la cible d'une campagne de
harcèlement sur les réseaux sociaux
menés par des collégiens plus âgés ce
nouveau phénomène apparu notamment sur
les réseaux tic toc et twiter qui
encourage les insultes et les menaces
envers les enfants nés en 2010 c'est
également prolongé dans les cours de
récréation où certains élèves ont été
agressés le harcèlement et le cyber
harcèlement scolaire qui ne connaît lui
aucune limite géographique ni
temporelles sont un véritable drame pour
les enfants qui en sont victimes et
peuvent avoir des conséquences
dramatiques
comme vous le savez monsieur le ministre
le sénat a mis en place une mission
d'information sur le harcèlement en
milieu scolaire et le cyber harcèlement
et elle doit rendre ses conclusions
cette semaine nous avons donc rencontré
de nombreux acteurs pour mieux
comprendre et tenter de mettre un terme
à ce phénomène
c'est en effet de notre responsabilité
de protéger les élèves d'aujourd'hui qui
seront les citoyens de demain si des
réponses exemplaires doivent être prises
contre les harceleurs il serait urgent
de réfléchir à l'image des pays du nord
à introduire les notions d'empathie et
de bienveillance au sein de notre école
publique
monsieur le ministre quelles mesures
comptez-vous prendre concrètement pour
éradiquer ce fléau qui touche notre
jeunesse déjà durement éprouvé par les
conséquences de l'épidémie ducobu de 19
on n'a pas roulé de l'éducation
nationale de la jeunesse et des sports
monsieur blanc qu'est la parole
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs à mme la
sénatrice corinne lepage là il y a
évidemment un sujet de société derrière
cette question du cyber harcèlement et
je vous remercie de la soulever
aujourd'hui la semaine dernière cela a
défrayé la chronique sur des bases
totalement absurde avec la montée en
puissance de ce mot diez non au 2010
c'est évidemment anti 2010 pardon
comme vous le savez j'ai réagi
immédiatement en lançant justement
quelque chose qui va dans le sens de la
bienveillance et de l'intégration des
élèves de 6e avec le #tsunami au 2010 il
est essentiel que nous ayons une
stratégie d'ensemble sur le cyber
harcèlement et c'est ce que nous faisons
depuis 2010 est en cette rentrée
s'applique dans tous les établissements
de france le programme intitulé phare
qui est un programme dans
anti-harcèlement inspiré en partie
d'ailleurs d'expérience scandinave
auquel vous avez fait référence et qui
conduit à responsabiliser tout le monde
d'abord par la formation des professeurs
sur cette question formation désormais
initial systématique de tous les
professeurs à ce sujet et formation
continue pour les professeurs qui
prennent cette responsabilité de
référents anti-harcèlement dans chaque
établissement de même nous
responsabilisons les élèves avec des
ambassadeurs contre le harcèlement en
chaque établissement de france c'est le
sens le plus important du programme
phare et avec de la formation pour ces
élèves là donc nous prenons ce sujet
très au sérieux nous avons deux
premières victoires et deux premières
limites les premières victoires nous les
avons contre le harcèlement nos chiffres
nous permettent de voir que ça a un peu
reculé depuis trois ans grâce à l'action
menée dans le sens que je viens
d'indiquer et la généralisation cette
année dans nous permettre d'avancer en
lien avec les associations très actives
sur ce sujet et puis en second lieu nous
de nous avons des limites avec le
cyberharcèlement vous avez rappelé que
n'avait pas de limite de temps ni
l'espace et donc je invité l'ensemble
des responsables de plateforme à venir
lundi prochain je serai en présence du
président du csa ans qu'olivier maistre
qui a des compétences en matière de
sanction des acteurs de l'audiovisuel
comme des plateformes de réseaux sociaux
de façon à écouter les propositions
qu'ils nous font nous avons des idées
très claires et très précises sur la
nécessité d'encadrer beaucoup plus ce
qui se passe pour les jeunes sur les
plateformes nous avons déjà pris des
mesures depuis 2010 est je pense à
l'interdiction des téléphones portables
au collège bien entendu je serai très
attentif dès cette semaine aux premières
conclusions de vos travaux qui sont
évidemment de la plus haute importance
et c'est donc la semaine prochaine après
les avoir écoutés que nous franchirons
une nouvelle étape dans la lutte contre
le cyber harcèlement je vous remercie
madame lepage
oui merci monsieur ministre je vous
remercie de votre réponse nous serons
tous très attentifs à vos propositions
pour régler ce problème peut-être pas
définitivement mais en tout cas pour
améliorer la situation et je voulais
dire pour terminer ma dernière
intervention que mon prénom et claudine
et non corinne merci vous ce mini
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à notre collègue philippe
tabarot pour le groupe des républicains
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le premier ministre
et j'y associe nos collègues valérie
boyer roger karoutchi monsieur le
premier ministre nous avons réclamé ici
au sénat des gestes pour les pieds noirs
et harkis les anciens combattants
notamment lors des différentes lois de
finances augmentation des crédits en
faveur du monde combattant proposition
de versement exceptionnel pour les
rapatrier votre majorité en rejeter
systématiquement nos propositions
soudainement et peut-être je dis bien
peut-être à quelques mois des élections
le souvenir rejaillit à l'elysée le
président macron demande pardon aux
harkis au nom de l'état avec une
nouvelle loi de réparation oui monsieur
le président les arts qui mérite que
leurs souffrances soient reconnus ils se
sont battus pour la france et la france
les a abandonnés cercle en même temps et
votre marque de fabrique b / en même
temps mémorielle est particulièrement
malvenu monsieur le premier ministre
mais questions sont claires comment
peut-on accuser comme emmanuel macron
l'a fait en algérie en février 2017 les
français de crimes contre l'humanité et
reconnaître en même temps les
souffrances de leurs fidèles soutiens
comment aller se recueillir devant le
monument des martyrs du fln à alger et
en même temps ne jamais se rendre sur
les charniers des pieds noirs et harkis
près du petit lac à oran après le
funeste 5 juillet 62 comment s'apprêtait
à célébrer en grande pompe le 60e
anniversaire des accords d'evian alors
que cette date marque une défaite pour
la france et le début d'un permis de
tuer ces mêmes harkis que vous prétendez
aujourd'hui mettre à l'honneur de
l'histoire de france pouvez vous donc
prendre l'engagement qu'aucun membre de
votre gouvernement ne participera aux
cérémonies du 19 mars prochain pour être
enfin cohérent avec vos discours
pour vous répondre la parole est à la
ministre délégué en charge de la mémoire
et des anciens combattants madame
darrieussecq
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur tabarot
le conflit d'algérie monsieur le
sénateur tabarot et vous l'avez dit dans
vos mots est en conflit complexe à la
mémoire complexe et surtout à des
mémoires multiples souvent rivales
et l'objectif du président de la
république est l'objectif que je me suis
assignées pendant ces quatre années où
quatre années un peu plus de quatre ans
est justement de faire en sorte que ces
mémoires se parlent
qu'elles soient toutes respectées et
qu'elle se respectent entre elles c'est
un objectif qui est ambitieux parce que
les choses sont difficiles mais je
souhaite véritablement et le président
de la république souhaite que le 60e
anniversaire
du hall de la fin de la guerre d'algérie
soit je sais que vous allez me dire que
ce n'est pas la fin soit l'occasion de
pouvoir honorer toutes ces mémoires
toutes ces mémoires la mémoire des
anciens combattants la mémoire des
harkis la mémoire des rapatriés et nous
avons d'ailleurs des actions
particulièrement intéressante menée par
l'office national des anciens
combattants où nous avons des anciens
qui viennent devant des jeunes en même
temps
anciens harkis anciens du fln ancien
rapatriés qui viennent ensemble
porter la parole devant ses jeunes
générations si à cela qu'il faut que
nous arrivions et je suis fier dans ce
gouvernement d'avoir porté de très
nombreuses actions pour les anciens
combattants pour les harkis et pour les
rapatrier et nous ferons le point de
tout ça notamment lorsque nous parlerons
loi sur les harkis proposée par le
président de la république et je crois
que ce débat doit être un débat apaisé
respectueux digne
[Applaudissements]
fondateurs thomas roux pour nous chères
madame le devoir de mémoire n'est pas à
la carte au gré des échéances
électorales voilà tout simplement ce que
je voulais vous dire
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à notre collègue sonia de
la provôté pour le groupe de l'union
centriste
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à madame
la ministre de l'enseignement supérieur
depuis juin des milliers et des milliers
d'étudiants se retrouve son master alors
qu'ils ont payé un lourd tribut à la
situation sanitaire cet obstacle à la
poursuite de leurs études les plonge
dans un profond désarroi depuis 2016 la
sélection se fait en effet l'entrée en
master 1 après l'obtention d'une licence
en cohérence avec le système lmd or
parallèlement à l'augmentation
considérable des effectifs de licences
ces dernières années l'offre de master
n'a pas été calibré à l'évolution de la
demande dans les filières ou l'obtention
d'une licence seul est insuffisante pour
accéder au marché du travail je pense
entre autres aux études de droit
consciente du problème à derna ministre
vous avez annoncé cet été la création de
nouvelles places dans les filières en
tension visiblement en nombre
insuffisant puisque les étudiants sont
encore des milliers à se précipiter sur
la plateforme gouvernementale trouvé mon
master point fr censé leur obtenir une
solution et nombreux sont ceux à qui la
plateforme ne propose rien de pertinent
ils sont de fait exclus exclus du
système
cette situation vide de son contenu le
droit à la poursuite d'études qui doit
garantir pourtant un parcours cohérent
madame la ministre vous pouvez vous
pouvez vous proposer à ses étudiants
plus largement comment entendez vous
conseillez droit la poursuite d'études
des sélections sans les opposer
pour vous répondre la parole est à la
ministre de l'enseignement supérieur de
la recherche et l'innovation comme
abidal
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
mesdames et sénatrice mais sébastien est
à même la sénatrice ce n'est de la
provôté vous savez je suis toujours très
attentive aux travaux du parlement en
général et de la haute assemblée en
particulier et donc je me souviens
parfaitement que le 9 septembre dernier
nous allons fêter le cinquième
anniversaire de la ppl de votre
prédécesseur
monsieur jean léonce dupont qui a
proposé de manière sèche la sélection à
l'entrée du masters
cet ep s est traduite par la loi du 23
décembre
qui a ajouté en même temps que la
sélection le droit à la poursuite
d'études vous voyez comme quoi le en
même temps a quand même quelques années
derrière lui et probablement quelques
belles années devant lui aussi alors
qu'est ce que nous faisons depuis cinq
ans eh bien depuis cinq ans nous
appliquons la loi et ce n'est pas un
problème quantitatif et je pense que
vous vous préoccupez suffisamment de ce
sujet pour le savoir il ya cent
cinquante mille diplômés de licence
générale chaque année il ya 170 mille
places en master alors même la sénatrice
moi la question que je pose aux
établissements et je suis évidemment à
côté d'eux pour cela c'est qu'elle est
l'insertion professionnelle est sorti du
masters non je vous rejoins c'est
qu'effectivement nous devons travailler
la question de l'insertion
professionnelle à la sortie de la
licence et c'est le cas puisque cette
année pour la première fois nous créons
des licences qui sont exclusivement
construite sur la base de blocs de
compétences
produits par les entreprises qui vont
ensuite recruté ces jeunes issus de
cette licence alors cette année
effectivement il y a un peu plus de 7300
demande sur la plateforme trouvé mon
master au passage il y en avait huit
mille cent l'année dernière nous avons
créé trois mille places supplémentaires
l'année dernière nous en avons créé 4400
cette année et comme dans le cas de
parcours sup un parent nous accompagnons
ces jeunes c'est déjà plus de 2500 qui
ont une solution et pour les autres eh
bien il nous faut là encore les aider à
accéder au masters s'ils le souhaitent à
condition qu'on puisse ensuite les
insérer professionnellement j'en ai mal
hommes de la provôté
oui madame la ministre vous l'avez
souligné c'était une vraie question à se
poser sur le contenu des licences ceci
dit vous dites vous appliquer la loi
depuis cinq ans
pour loin c'est quand même un problème
d'anticipation on est passé quand même
de deux millions cad étudiants en 2013 à
plus de 2 millions us pour cette rentrée
actuelle et il ya fort à parier que le
nombre de sortants de licences cette
année soit très augmenté donc la
question c'est l'urgence en réalité
faute d'anticipation c'était en dehors
de l'augmentation du nombre de places
qu'allez vous proposer de façon rapide
et effective dans les halls et pour les
universités vaut qu'elle puisse prendre
en charge ce surcroît de licenciés qui
vont sortir à la fin de l'année
universitaire et qui n'auront pas de
solution comme cette année comme l'année
précédente
et comme les années précédentes sur vos
merci merci la parole est maintenant
notre collègue henri leroy pour le
groupe les république tél
[Applaudissements]
mais chez le président monsieur le
premier ministre
mesdames et messieurs les munichois
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de l'intérieur qui
n'est pas là mais
après sept mois de concertation de
déplacement et des changes autour du
bureau de la sécurité le mardi 4
septembre dernier à roubaix le président
de la république nous livrer ses
propositions pour la sécurité des
français il était temps il était temps
monsieur le premier ministre quatre ans
après l'élection présidentielle que des
mesures soient annoncées
entre temps de 2016 à 2020 l'écho et
blessures volontaires ont augmenté de 36
% presque 800 agressions par jour des
violences à l'encontre des dépositaires
de l'autorité publique ont également et
augmenté de 12% presque 100 par jour
dans notre beau pays il y à une violence
gratuite toutes les 44 secondes et un
refus d'obtempérer toutes les 30 minutes
il était temps monsieur le ministre à
quelques mois d'aidé des élections que
le président de la république entende
l'appel du sénat et des forces de
sécurité
simplification des procédures pénales
meilleure prise en charge des victimes
formation et soutien plus performants
aux policiers aux gendarmes
tout cela nous le proposions déjà en
2018 c'est dans le rapport du sénat sur
l'état des forces de sécurité la
création d'une réserve opérationnelle de
la police c'est aussi une proposition du
sénat fait en début d'année vous l'avez
compris monsieur le ministre je me
réjouis que l'ensemble du travail
accompli par notre institution était et
est repris mais le président de la
république aura du mal à mettre en place
ces réformes dans un temps court ma
question est simple puisque c'est le
ministère de l'intérieur le ministre de
l'intérieur qui en est chargé
donnez nous un calendrier au moins près
de mise en oeuvre des engagements
présidentiels
merci
pour vous répondre par les cas la
ministre délégué en charge de la
citoyenneté wallemme schiappa avez la
parole
merci monsieur le président mesdames les
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs et
monsieur le sénateur henri leroy tout
d'abord je tiens à vous remercier au nom
du ministre de l'intérieur gérald
darmanin qui n'est pas là mais que je
représente en son nom et en mon nom
propre aujourd'hui en tant que ministre
délégué à l'intérieur pour votre
participation assidue et constructive au
débat du beau jeu de la sécurité vous
avez porté avec force pendant tout le
temps du beau jeu de la sécurité la voie
de la représentation nationale et
surtout vous avez montré le soutien de
celle ci à nos forces de sécurité
intérieure je crois que c'est bien là
l'essentiel
et je tiens à vous en remercier le
pauvre de la sécurité ça a été un temps
d'échangé de travail directs sans
chiffre continue qui a permis d'écouter
la réalité du terrain de trouver des
solutions concrètes et le ministère de
l'intérieur y apporter un engagement
sans faille suite à ce beau jeu de la
sécurité le président de la république a
entendu les préoccupations des
françaises et des français et de nos
forces de sécurité intérieure et le
président a annoncé de nombreuses
mesures concrètes que vous connaissez je
pense notamment à l'augmentation de 1,5
milliard d'euros du budget du ministère
de l'intérieur pour 2022 qui va
permettre de soutenir encore davantage
l'effort en faveur de la sécurité et de
la tranquillité des français engagés
depuis 2017 et vous le savez puisque
vous avez voté l'augmentation du budget
du ministère de l'intérieur
au delà de l'augmentation est de
l'engagement du gtr sans précédent nous
présenterons en début d'année prochaine
une loi d'orientation et de
programmation pour la sécurité
intérieure qui structurera encore
davantage notre police notre gendarmerie
et au delà bien sur l'ensemble du
ministère à l'horizon 2030 je veux dire
pour conclure que le président de la
république a aussi rappelé avec force
que l'état c'est tout ce qui est en son
pouvoir mais ne peut pas tout tous seuls
le continuum de sécurité entre l'état et
les maires est fondamental dans notre
approche commune de la sécurité des
français il cela passe par
l'augmentation des moyens dédiés à la
vidéo protection et ce dès 2021 c'est
donc en ce sens est consciente du souci
particulier de la chambre haute pour les
collectivités locales que je veux
rappeler ici que quatre maires ont
participé activement beauvau de la
sécurité et que l'enfant des
associations dia lui ils ont transmis
une contribution je tiens ici à les en
remercier pour cet engagement
fondamental et à leurs heures que le
gouvernement continuera d'être à leurs
côtés je vous remercie
la parole est maintenant notre collègue
jean michel lungart pour le groupe
socialiste écologiste
monsieur le président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues je voudrais revenir
sur la rupture du contrat australien
nous avons eu à cherbourg comme en
france un sentiment de stupéfaction face
à la brutalité de l'annoncé de la
rupture de ce que l'on a appelé le
contrat du siècle puis nous sommes
passés de la sidération à la tristesse
d'une perte de confiance d'un sentiment
de trahison de la part de ceux qui sont
nos alliés tristesse aussi pour tous
ceux qui se sont investis pour ce projet
ceux qui se sont expatriés à adélaïde
mais aussi pour ces familles
australiennes qui ont réussi leur
implantation à cherbourg aujourd'hui
domine l'amertume et l'inquiétude
amertume sur le fait que nous aurions
fait preuve de naïveté sans anticiper
décoder et répondre aux attentes sur
l'évolution des besoins australien nous
contentant d'un excès de confiance en
nous mêmes de propos incantatoires mais
cela sera le travail de la commission
denquête que nous appelons de nos voeux
inquiétudes surtout sur le devenir des
650 salariés qui travaillent en france
sur le projet sur le devenir des 350
personnes basée en australie et sur nos
entreprises françaises sous traitante de
biens comme jeumont electric ou de
services comme fiva ou d'autres qui avec
l'accompagnement de business france ont
créé des joint-ventures et ont investi
en australie inquiétude aussi pour le
devenir de nos industries de défense qui
enregistre un nouveau camouflet après
l'échec de la vente de rafale à la
suisse après un tremblement de terre au
delà des ruines il y à des personnes
sous les décombres et des édifices
fragilisés
aussi madame la ministre quelles mesures
économiques et sociales concrètes l'état
mettra-t-il en place pour accompagner
les salariés des entreprises qui vont
faire face à la rupture de charge
brutale et sont plus fragiles
économiquement et moins armé
juridiquement est il envisageable
notamment d'avancer les études du
programme de sous-marins de troisième
génération pour mobiliser les moyens en
ingénierie qui vont s'avérer disponibles
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les milices les gens mais merci monsieur
le président mesdames et messieurs le
sénateur monsieur le sénateur tout
d'abord permettez moi de rendre hommage
à naval groupe à toutes les entreprises
françaises aux ingénieurs et aux
militaires qui pendant plus de quatre
ans se sont donné pour ce programme
d'armement notre industrie navale figure
parmi les meilleurs du monde et c'est
une fierté de cultiver en france des
savoir faire unique qui sont connus et
reconnus et qui permettent à notre
marine nationale d'être l'une des
meilleures du monde
la rupture de ce contrat c'est un coup
porté un coup porté à nos emplois sans
compter les sous-traitants que vous avez
énuméré monsieur le sénateur 650
personnes un aval groupe france et 350
personnes de naval groupe australie sont
impliqués dans ce programme aujourd'hui
et je sais la mobilisation de cherbourg
pour réserver le meilleur accueil aux
salariés et aux dizaines d'australiens
ainsi que leurs familles qui se sont
installées et qui ont qui s'est traduit
par la mise à disposition de logements
de service d'école adapté aux besoins de
ces personnes alors
aujourd'hui qu'allons-nous faire et bien
nous n'allons pas nous laisser faire
nous allons aider nos entreprises à
passer ce cap et cela de deux manières
tout d'abord en sortant par le haut les
études qui ont déjà été réalisés seront
payés jusqu'au dernier centime et nous
ne ferons aucun cadeau contractuels la
deuxième c'est par le soutien du
ministère qui est mobilisée aux côtés de
naval groupe aux côtés des collectivités
territoriales concernées pour trouver
des solutions et assuré le maintien des
compétences et dans cette perspective
vous l'avez rappelé le récent lancement
en réalisation du sous marin nucléaire
lanceur d'engins de troisième génération
ainsi que les travaux qui portent sur le
porte avions du futur qui sont des
grands programmes qui ont été lancés
grâce à la loi de programmation
militaire
nous y aidera beaucoup grâce à cette loi
de programmation militaire et mais aussi
grâce aux nombreux succès à
l'exportation monsieur le sénateur car
il y en a eu beaucoup cours de cette
période plus de trente six mille emplois
ont été créés depuis 2010 est dans les
entreprises de défense alors nous
n'avons pas fait tout cela pour en
supprimer aujourd'hui
merci la parole est maintenant notre
collègue
annick petrus pour le groupe l'est
républicain on avait la parole
monsieur le président mais chez un
collègue ma question s'adresse au
ministre des solidarités de la santé
monsieur le ministre la vague épidémique
de covile 19 sans précédent qui a frappé
les antilles dont saint martin a mis en
exergue la fragilité structurelle des
systèmes de santé de nos territoires
respectifs
ainsi la situation critique a connu
notre centre hospitalier louis constant
fleming est exceptionnel mais
révélatrice de graves carences dont
souffre notre territoire et pose de
légitimes interrogations
déjà fortement sous dotées en termes de
moyens financiers matériels et humains
le centre hospitalier fait face à des
enjeux inique
implantée à 260 kilomètres de son
chiffre déférence en guadeloupe et
malgré sa petite taille c'est le seul
recours pour la population de saint
martin et de saint barthélémy à ce type
il doit être capable de répondre à
l'ensemble des besoins urgents c'est en
première intention pour les soins
courants ne disposant pas de toutes les
compétences on dénombre environ 200
d'évacuation sanitaire annuel vers les
chu de guadeloupe et de martinique
charge particulièrement lourde en termes
de personnel et de finance plus de deux
millions d'euros annuels obérant
sensiblement le budget du ch l'hôpital
ne devrait en aucun cas subir ses coûts
de plus les restrictions horaires de
décollage et d'atterrissage des avions
impossible la nuit peuvent entraîner un
important retard de prise en charge et
une réelle perte de chance pour nos
passions oui on meurt à saint-martin
faute de disponibilité de l'hélicoptère
de la sécurité civile de la guadeloupe
oui le temps d'attentes pour des
analyses à l'hôpital et de deux heures
minimum faute d'un laboratoire
d'analysés disponibles h/24 et le cese
caennais au privé de l'île et éloigne du
ch si on ajoute à ça les aléas
climatiques liés à la saison cyclonique
nous pouvons être coupé de toute liaison
vers les chu voisin pendant plusieurs
jours monsieur le ministre comptez-vous
prendre des mesures puisque des
solutions existent que comptez vous
faire pour qu'enfin nos trois centres
hospitaliers puisse répondre aux
exigences d'un établissement isolé et
ainsi garantir à la population saint
martinoise une prise en charge répondant
aux mêmes la diligence cassé alors
acquis sur le territoire hexagonal en
termes d'accès aux soins et l'égalité
des chances pour vous répondre
parce que leur ministre délégué en
charge de l'économie
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice annie petrus permettez moi
tout d'abord de dire que grâce à la
mobilisation très forte des soignants de
notre pays plus de 2000 qui sont partis
de métropole la situation en outre-mer
s'améliore même si bien sûr la vigilance
reste de mise notamment en polynésie
comme vous le savez mais je voudrais
quand même qu'on salue cet effort
colossal qui s'est réalisé y compris sur
la prouesse à l'évacuation sanitaire qui
s'est faite entre la polynésie et la
métropole qui arrive pour la première
fois en france et qui a permis de sauver
des personnes vous avez raison de
rappeler qu'en toutes circonstances
on doit permettre un meilleur accès aux
soins évidemment à tous nos concitoyens
et pour maintenir cette promesse
républicaine il est nécessaire d'y aller
collectivités par collectivité très
finement et la réponse pour trouver la
réponse la plus adaptée le ségur de la
santé vient à l'échelle nationale
mobilisé 15 points 5 milliards de
manière pluriannuelle cet historique en
ce qui concerne votre territoire saint
martin se caractérise vous l'avez
rappelé par sa double insularité
nous devons donc tâcher d'apporter la
réponse la plus indiquée à votre
territoire pour permettre que ces
résidents disposent de l'offre la plus
consolidée possible danzé déjà sur les
territoires couverts par l' agence
gaudeloupe saint martin et saint
barthélémy de santé nous mobiliserons 10
millions d'euros pour cette première
année en complément nous allons
mobiliser sur des projets
d'investissement sanitaire 98 millions
d'euros en plus des 46 millions d'euros
mobilisés pour l'assainissement
financier sans compter les
investissements en matière médico-social
les besoins établis pour saint martin
sont estimées à 17 5 millions d'euros
pour répondre au tome notamment besoin
d'accès aux soins directement depuis
saint martin par le développement d'un
laboratoire notamment et de divers
plateaux ce que vous évoquiez la demande
d'investissement formulées par le centre
hospitalier
louis constant fleming est en cours
d'examen par l' agence de santé et une
attention particulière sera apportée à
la situation de saint martin la
stratégie territoriale d'investissement
devra être consolidée mi octobre c'est
d'ailleurs ce pourquoi le président
daniel gibbs sera reçu dès lundi
prochain au ministère des solidarités la
santé
merci la parole est un autre collègue
laurent burgoa pour le groupe l'est
républicain
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre l'épisode cévenol que le gars a
connu la semaine dernière s'inscrit
malheureusement dans une continuité en
quelques heures s'est abattu plus de
deux mois de précipitations
280 mm les inondations du 14 septembre
dernier ne sont pas que des images
impressionnantes que l'on passe en
boucle sur les chaînes d'information
les habitants y perdent parfois en
proche leur bien des souvenirs et une
fois ces inondations vécu ne se sentent
plus jamais en sécurité car oui après
1988 2002 2003 2005 2014 et 2020 elles
sont désormais récurrente et comme de
nombreux élus des départements du sud de
la france je ne me résous pas en
confiant la compétence gym a pu oser pci
l'état n'a pas transférer des moyens
nécessaires bien sûr vous évoquerez sans
doute la possibilité de lever cette
nouvelle taxe devrait maintenant mais
voyez vous certains territoires à cette
année sur plus de 200 kilomètres carrés
et compte moins de 21 mille habitants
alors que les investissements attendus
sont considérables le plafond
mobilisables pour ces territoires ne
sera jamais suffisant du fait de ses
caractéristiques géographiques et des
mangroves démographique la protection de
nos concitoyens passe par des
investissements lourds de plusieurs
millions d'euros pour ne prendre qu'un
exemple la comète de communautaire de
camargue est à laval 2-3 berthe bassin
versant qui représente près de 20% du
territoire national il faut que l'état
et incarne et finance la solidarité
amont aval dont nous avons besoin ma
question est la suivante êtes vous prête
à soutenir à une hauteur réceptionner
dans le financement des ouvrages
nécessaires je vous remercie
vous répondre la parole et secrétaire
d'état
ministre merci monsieur le président
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur burgoa le gard
effectivement a été touché un lien peu
moins d'une semaine par des intempéries
des inondations dramatiques et permettez
moi d'abord d'adresser un mot de
solidarité à tous les gardois et les
gardoises qui qui ont été touchés par
ces événements exceptionnels des
événements qui malheureusement nous le
savons dans ce contexte de changement
climatique vont augmenter à la fois en
termes de fréquence et en terme
d'intensité vous êtes très bien placé
malheureusement pour pour le savoir nous
devons nous y préparer et cette
prévention elle s'effectue d'abord dans
les moyens que nous avons vis dans les
capacités de prévision de météo france
avec vous le savez un nouveau
supercalculateur à toulouse qui
représente 144 millions d'euros
d'investissements pour nous permettre
d'abord d'anticiper les zones impactées
les horizons prévisions en les
inventions de plusieurs heures nous
permettent une gestion anticipée de des
crises à venir effectivement ça ne
répond pas aux besoins de réparation des
dégâts exceptionnels qui sont qui sont
reconnus sur ces territoires l'état
accompagne évidemment les collectivités
vous l'avais dit dans cette prévention
grâce au fonds barnier d'abord fonds
barnier que nous avons renforcé début
2021 avec 50% crédits supplémentaires
qui atteignait
ja donc aujourd'hui de 105 millions
d'euros et qui ont été encore augmenter
ce jour de 30 millions dans le projet de
loi de finances qui vient de vous être
de nous être présenté et qui viennent
compléter les ressources de la gema pis
avec également de nouvelles ressources
financières qui sont envisagées évoqué
pour mettre en place cette solidarité de
bassin versant les agences de l'eau qui
sont très actives dans l'accompagnement
de ces projets auprès des collectivités
pour rétablir des réseaux d'eau potable
d'assainissement financer des zones
d'expansion de crues ou des
restaurations de rivière et et sur ses
relations je crois entre les agences et
les au ptb les établissements publics
territoriaux de bassin je crois que nous
devons préserver cette solidarité et
cette échelle cette échelle des grands
bassins même si évidemment
la monde doit être
conscient des impacts sur laval 7
soleils cette solidarité elle existe et
je pense qu'elle doit être préservé et
puis vous dire également et le ministre
d'arman ans y était engagé sur place il
y à un peu plus d'une semaine que la
déclaration d'état de catastrophe
naturelle a bien été prise en compte
donc dans des délais très très contraint
je suis en mesure de vous annoncer que
la commission interministérielle qui
doit avoir lieu demain nous laisse
espérer un arrêté catnat publié ce
week-end afin que chacun puisse au plus
vite se reconstruire jean massives
subies en bois vous avez quelques
secondes merci monsieur le président à
événement exceptionnel mesures
exceptionnelles et excusez moi madame la
ministre mais je crois que vos propos ne
rompt pas rassuré les élus locaux
merci
le drévo rappelé mes chers collègues
nous en avons fini c'est le premier
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
ministres de questions au gouvernement
je vous rappelle que nos prochaines
questions au lieu le 29 septembre à 15
heures mercredi la science va être
suspendue elle sera prise à 16h35 pour
la suite de la proposition de loi visant
à protéger la rémunération des
agriculteurs
notre séance est suspendue
[Musique]
voilà donc pour ces questions
d'actualité au gouvernement une séance
largement presque entièrement on va
presque exagéré entièrement consacré aux
sous marins à la crise des sous marins
avec l'australie à ce que certains
n'hésitent plus à qualifier de trahison
du siècle sans perdre de temps on va
rejoindre l'hémicycle on retrouve jérôme
jérôme et qu'est ce que vous avez retenu
de cette séance à bastille vin vous le
dit c'était le sujet attendu on n'a pas
été déçu florence par lui par lee a dû
faire face au feu des questions 1 des
sénateurs sur ce dossier des sous marins
dès la deuxième question rachid fait mal
a été offensif le sénateur socialiste
portait la demande un des sénateurs de
son parti d'une création de commission
d' enquête sur cette volte-face
australienne il a critiqué la gestion du
gouvernement
écoutez le sénateur du val-d'oise
jamais depuis l'avènement l'a5 nique la
france d'un connu une telle humiliation
oui monsieur prémices de la france et
humilié bien sûr nous condamnons comme
vous monsieur près ministre les
agissements de nos alliés américains
britanniques et australiens mais force
est de constater que cette affaire dit
des sous marins australiens en dit long
sur votre gouvernance est votre bilan
une question qui a provoqué le courroux
de la ministre des armées florence parly
elle a dénoncé la rupture de l'unité
nationale sur ce dossier et a enflammé
l'hémicycle par une phrase je vous
laisse revivre ce moment
permettez-moi d'être étonné pour ne pas
dire choquée d'entendre dans cet
hémicycle un responsable et un
représentant de la nation donner le
sentiment qu'au fond ce qui arrive à la
france est plutôt un motif d'
instrumentalisation du débat politique
interne plutôt que plutôt que deux
plutôt que monsieur le sénateur de
considérer que c'est la france sa place
dans le monde et ses relations avec ses
partenaires ses alliés au premier rang
desquels les états unis qui est en débat
vous comprendrez bien monsieur le
sénateur qu' on ne peut pas réécrire
l'histoire a posteriori ou alors
évidemment on s'érige en juge ou en
procureur ce ce que non je comprends
d'ailleurs que c'est l'intention du
sénat et vous aurez
[Musique]
alors on ne voit pas tout sur ces images
mais ici depuis l'hémicycle depuis la
tribune de presse on a vu quasiment
l'intégralité de l'hémicycle qui s'est
mis à taper sur les pupitres empêchant
la ministre de poursuivre sa réponse au
bout d'une trentaine de secondes gérard
larcher a ramené le can difficilement
tout en précisant à l'adresse de
florence parly que les provocations non
pas une utilité absolue pour le débat
après cette bronca la ministre a
temporisé rappelant qu'elle se tenait
évidemment à la disposition du sénat
pour répondre pour conclure à tchité mal
dans son droit de réplique à dénoncer
les propos de la ministre qui selon lui
montrent bien la nécessité d'une
commission d' enquête sur ce sujet mais
les prochains échanges entre la ministre
des armées et les sénateurs risque
d'être bien tendue après cette remise en
cause des prérogatives du sénat par
florence parler merci beaucoup jérôme un
sénat qui se transforme en procureur les
mots de florence parly sont très forts
je suis sûr que bruno retailleau aura
quelque chose à dire il à votre micro
quentin festive bonjour bruno retailleau
bonjour résidents du groupe elle est ici
au sénat qu'est ce que vous pensez
qu'elle est votre commentaire après ses
propos de florence parly sur une
intention du sénat qui serait d'être
juges et procureurs dans la sphère des
sous marins qu'est ce que ça vous avoir
évoqué cette accusation écoutez quand un
ministre ou une ministre perd ses nerfs
perd son calme c'est qu'il est malade s
il faut que le gouvernement des mails
macron supporte qu'il y un parle dans le
rôle du parlement c'est pas seulement de
faire la loi le rôle du parlement c'est
aussi de contrôler l'action du
gouvernement est ce que cette affaire
des sous marins nucléaires
américain est ce que cette affaire de la
rupture du contrat français avec
l'australie est une affaire d'état est
quelque chose d'extrêmement important
oui c'est parfaitement normal que nous
nous posions des questions et la
commission des affaires étrangères va
convoquer monsieur le drian mais aussi
le patron du renseignement etc et nous
sommes dans notre rôle c'est la
démocratie il faut qu'on aime paris se
rendent compte que la france c'est quand
même un état de droit et une démocratie
et dans une démocratie il ya une
séparation des pouvoirs est dans une
démocratie le parlement contrôle aussi
l'action des gouvernements pas pour se
faire plaisir à lui à nous mais
simplement parce que nos mandants ce
sont les français est ce qu'on pense
aussi qu'il ya un problème qui se pose
dans les services de renseignement qui
n'ont pas vu venir ce qui s'est joué ces
derniers mois chez les australiens ex
époux dans la raquette on ne nous fera
pas croire qu' il n'y avait pas des
signes avant-coureurs un certain nombre
d' indices d'ailleurs le prouve mais je
ne veux pas anticiper les travaux de la
commission des affaires étrangères en
tout cas il faut quitter une forme de
naïveté la naïveté c'est de croire que
il suffit de remplacer monsieur tron par
monsieur byden pour que l'amérique
devienne notre grande a dit monsieur
byden proclame à l'assemblée générale
des nations unies son goût pour le
multilatéralisme et monsieur van dijk et
tabor américains et pour monsieur
buydens ses amis que first voilà c'est
tout il est simplement plus courtois
peut-être un peu plus civilisée que
monsieur trump mais le reste ne change
pas et cette affaire là nous montre qu'
il ya une sorte d' angles aux sphères
liées par la langue l'anglais liés par
une civilisation une culture et ça prend
le pas bien entendu sur d'autres
considérations commerciales ou non
retailleau un dernier mois si vous le
voulez bien sur l'actualité de votre
famille politique les a l'air et ce
rapport remis par jean leonetti à gérard
larcher à quai sur jacob qui pose deux
possibilités pour les militants une
primaire semi ouverte avec les
centristes et une autre réservée aux
militants à l'air qu'est ce que vous
allez prenez vous comme solution auprès
de votre famille politique dont les
cadres sont réunis aujourd'hui j'ai
jamais quitté bas position je veux un
vote parce que dans une démocratie quand
les sondages n'ont pas eu le bon goût de
doute et partager c'est à dire se faire
de travail alors il faut s'en remettre
au vote personnes votant le droit
personne ne doit craindre une
compétition avec un vote c'est le
fondement encore une fois les
démocraties modernes qu'est ce que je
souhaite c'est que les votants soit non
seulement les adhérents mais aussi les
sympathisants pour donner un élan une
légitimité qui est la condition du
rassemblement ensuite d'ailleurs ces
enquêtes 1 qui seront examinés à cet
après midi damien abad lui dit le chef
de file donc votre homologue à
l'assemblée nationale gilles des députés
il estime qu'il faut privilégier le
mieux placé pour l'emporter vous le
dites qu'il a tort non je veux dire que
lorsque on s'inscrit dans une filiation
gaulliste
on essaie de faire en sorte que les
sondages ne détermine pas l'avenir de la
france mais ce sont les suffrages c'est
à dire le peuple en tout cas l'électorat
de droite militants plus sympathisants
qui doit reprendre le contrôle des
choses merci bruno retailleau chef de
file dlr ici au sénat d'avoir répondu à
nos questions en direct sur public sénat
merci beaucoup quentin pour refaire ces
questions d'actualité jakl sur ce
plateau lance cohen bonjour sénatrice
communiste du val de marne dominique
estrosi sassone bonjour bonjour vous
êtes sénatrice les républicains des
alpes-maritimes et puis rachid tu es mal
on vous a entendu pendant ces questions
d'actualité sénateur socialiste de
l'oise petite question l'oise le val
d'oise j'ai dit quoi de l'oise val
d'oise
c'est quand même le plus beau
département du cher en temps laurence
cohen sur cette question des sous marins
on a l'impression que droite et gauche
sont un peu d'accord sur cette question
vous parlez vous d'affaires d'état à
écouter nous nous avons posé une
question en tout cas c'est mon collègue
pierre laurent qui a posé la question
donc plusieurs remarques d'abord moi je
partage ce qu'on dit plusieurs de mes
collègues exter c'est quand même
inadmissible que les ministres dans les
hémicycles puisse avoir une charge assez
violente envers le sénat et confondre
les choses on est on est en démocratie
on a un rôle de contrôle on légifère on
a un rôle de contrôle et il m'a pas
semblé que mon collègue et dépasser ses
prérogatives en posant cette question ça
c'est la première chose deuxième chose
je crois que c'est extrêmement important
aussi de remettre en cause la politique
est de la france par rapport à son
indépendance mais aussi des états unis
et de voir ce qu'il faut faire par
rapport à l'otan par rapport à l'europe
nous nous sommes pour le retrait de
l'otan parce que nous pensons qu'il faut
reconquérir l'indépendance de la france
travailler dans la coopération et
qu'aujourd'hui ça n'est pas le cas on a
vu en plus que les états unis là il ya
les sous marins mais enfin il ya
quelques semaines la politique qu'il
mène au niveau par exemple de
l'afghanistan avec un retrait tel qu'il
a été pratiqué donc pour livre un pays
aux talibans c'est extrêmement lourde de
conséquence donc il faut que la france
reprenne la main alors je vais vous
laisser répondre tous les deux mais
juste avant j'aimerais qu'on retrouve
quand un calme et en salle des
conférences qu en tant qu elle mais vous
êtes avec sarah est la grille secrétaire
d'état chargée de la jeunesse peut-être
qu'elle a des annonces à faire sur le
revenu d'engagement pour les jeunes mais
c'est vrai qu'en ce moment au parlement
il ya deux actualités fortes steve 1 est
ce qu'on vient de dire d'évoquer sur les
sous marins et à la présentation
forcément du budget ce matin en conseil
des ministres bonjour ça à l'aérés
bonjour il a été question de ce budget
en conseil des ministres avec notamment
un trou celui qui concerne aussi votre
ministère car on attend toujours des
annonces sur le revenu langage pour les
jeunes ça pourrait représenter un trou
de deux milliards d'euros dans le budget
est-ce que vous pouvez nous faire des
annonces sur le financement de ce revenu
déjà le plus important c'est moins le
financement que l'objectif de ce revenu
d'engagement sont venus d'engagement il
a vocation à accompagner plus d'un
million de jeunes aujourd'hui qui sont
sans emploi sans formation
jamais de l'argent investi pour notre
jeunesse sera considérée par nous comme
une dépense malheureuse ou pas
suffisante 9 milliards d'euros je le
rappelle le plein jeu une solution
aujourd'hui c'est un nouvel élan c'est
la naissance d'un nouveau droit et les
annonces seront faites dans les jours et
semaines qui arrivent est ce que vous
comprenez le désarroi notamment ici au
sénat en commission des finances on ne
peut pas travailler sur les mesures de
cet apport qui sera fait à tous les
jeunes parce qu'on n'a pas encore bien
tout le détail dans le document qui va
être déposée sur le bureau des chambres
je comprends tout à fait cette ce
désarroi pour reprendre votre terme
parce que j'ai été moi-même députées et
députés de la commission des finances
étant moi-même rapportera l'époque du
budget jeunesse vie associative et sport
je vois bien la nécessité de se projeter
cela étant dit le budget est ambitieux
pour la jeunesse en particulier les la
loi de finances est un moment de débat
intense qui se trouve que sur le revenu
d'engagement les derniers échanges et
dernière construction parce qu'il est
écrit avec les mouvements de jeunesse
avec les associations de jeunesse alors
nous prenons ces derniers moments et
bien pour le finaliser le présente
évidemment la représentation nationale
et bien cette opposition nationale elle
dit aussi c'est votre opposition est lui
aussi que les vannes sont grandes
ouvertes que la carte bancaire du
gouvernement est devenue folle ce sont
les propos là de jean françois husson
qu'elle rapporteur général du budget ici
est ce que vous êtes déjà en campagne
avec notamment la mesure que vous allez
pouvoir porter franchement jamais on
peut dire ça pour la jeunesse vous avez
vu à quel point elle a résisté elle a
investi elle a pris sur elle est là pour
une partie d'entre elles souffert de
cette crise c'est notre avenir c'est ce
qu'on a de plus précieux la compagne et
financièrement par la formation en
accompagnant les emplois en accompagnant
l'économie c'est la plus belle chose
qu'on puisse faire pour notre pays donc
non il n'y aura pas de dépenses qu'on
puisse considérer comme folle pour notre
jeunesse au contraire c'est un
accompagnement jour par jour besoin par
besoin et jeunes par jeunes un tout
dernier mot juste pour nous expliquer ce
revenu dans gages pour les jeunes que
vous que vous allez porter est-ce
qu'elle des arbitrages et questions sur
la façon dont ça allait fonctionner les
annonces très opérationnels vont être
faites dans quelques dans quelques temps
le plus long a été fait mais surtout ce
qui compte pour nous c'est comme c'est
travailler avec les jeunes avec les
différentes structures qui vont le faire
le plus important c'est que ça réponde
aux besoins des jeunes quelles que
soient leurs territoires et quelle que
soit leur situation et vous viendra
plus merci d'être venus sur au micro
public sénat en direct aujourd'hui si
vous avez tout essayé quand on merci
beaucoup on aura pas d'annoncés très
précises sur ce revenu d'engagement pour
les jeunes jamais qu'on revienne à
présent sur cette crise des sous marins
sur ce que certains ont appelé la
trahison du siècle racheté mal vous vous
demandez une commission d enquête
pourquoi qu'est ce que vous voulez
savoir qui voulez vous entendre les
choses sont simples je crois que la
france n'a jamais été autant humilié sur
la scène internationale que ces derniers
jours et depuis maintenant une semaine
nous avons une gesticulation
diplomatique qui assez triste et
pathétique et je crois pas au niveau de
ce qu'est la france est donc comme nous
avons plusieurs versions personne ne
sait nous dire ce qui s'est passé
personne ne sait nous dire pourquoi
pendant plusieurs semaines plusieurs
mois je crois que les américains
australiens et les britanniques ont
négocié à la fin de votre contrat une
alliance stratégique et qu' aucun
français n'était au courant donc je
considère et nous considérons et je ne
crois pas qu'il ya seulement mon groupe
je prenne d'autres également on
considère que dieu lui un problème c'est
le moins qu'on puisse dire et donc il
est normal qu'on garde ce qui s'est
passé parce que si on sait ce qui s'est
passé on peut faire en sorte de prendre
des points somme de décisions pour
éviter de retrouver cela à nouveau parce
que le contrat du siècle il est parti
parce que la france qui est une
puissance dans le monde indo pacifique
pour l'instant les marginaliser bon je
crois qu'il ya des vrais enjeux le pense
aux anneaux à nos concitoyens nouveau
calédoniens et d'autres qui sont
aujourd'hui quasiment livrés à eux mêmes
dont je considère nous considérons qui a
besoin de cette commission d'enquêté je
ne peux que regretter le dérapage une
ministre dans les missiles qui en fait
de jouer le procureur bien sûr que si on
pose des questions et nous sommes
procurés rien su c'est un sujet je crois
que nous sommes en démocratie et encore
une fois nous faisons que notre travail
nous sommes là pour à la fois faire la
loi et contrôlée
l'action du gouvernement comme le
prévoit la convention française donc si
madame par lee a une difficulté c'était
qu'à la conscience française et moi
j'espère que le présent atomique va très
vite a expliqué madame paris ce qu'est
le rôle de ministre dominique estrosi
sassone est ce que vous êtes d'accord on
n'a pas entendu emmanuel macron encore
s'exprimer à ce qu'il doit le faire est
ce qu'il doit faire un point presse sur
cette crise des sous-marins seulement en
tout cas je trouve que emmanuel macron
le silence des manuels macro est
particulièrement assourdissant il faut
aujourd'hui attendent presque une
semaine pour qu'on puisse avoir
l'information comme quoi un rendez vous
téléphonique de la plus haute importance
entre le président de la république
française joe biden soit organisée à
l'heure de la communication immédiate on
peut pas continuer ça fait pratiquement
une semaine qu'on continue à se
contenter des larmes de crocodile de
monsieur le drian effectivement le
président de la république c'est à lui
de s'expliquer c'est à lui de parler non
seulement sur la crise des sous marins
australiens mais aussi on en attend
beaucoup plus on attend aussi de
connaître du président emmanuel macron
quelle est la nouvelle voie diplomatique
pour la france dans cette zone indo
pacifique florence parly nous disaient
qu'ils avaient pas forcément de
changements au niveau stratégique ans
aujourd'hui oui mais encore faudra-t-il
que le président a république porte
cette voie là et que puisse dire audi
dire on sait pas où va l'eau tant que
veut l'europe ce sont autant de
questions qu'il appartient au président
de la république de donner des réponses
des réponses devant les françaises et
des français mais aussi et comme l'on
dit mes collègues je pense que la
représentation nationale est
parfaitement dans son rôle que d'exiger
des réponses et de pouvoir savoir s'il
ya eu ou non des dysfonctionnements dans
la diplomatie français alors justement
précisément je vous propose d'écouter
florence parly pour qui et bien cette
affaire n'invalide pas la stratégie
française dans la région écoutez la
l'annulation de ce contrat vous l'avez
dit une invalides pas une stratégie en
ado pacifique ce que nous proposons aux
acteurs de la région c'est une stratégie
qui est en quelque sorte une alternative
face au modèle chinois et dont
l'objectif est clair refusé d'être
l'otage
la rivalité entre la chine et les états
unis nous affirmons non seulement la
nécessité pour l'europe de protéger son
espace propre mais aussi d'être capable
de se projeter au-delà des frontières de
l'union européenne
chaque fois et partout où ses intérêts
sont en jeu agitez mal non je pourrais
panda mise parce qu'avec ladislas
poniatowski nous avons fait un rapport
sur notamment cette zone là il faut je
crois que la miss de 2 a du mal avec ses
fiches en fait on pas dire à la fois
c'est un contrat du siècle qui permet à
la france est une puissance forte de
cette zone là une fois que nous aurons
perdu contre 1 qu' il ya une alliance
qui s'est fait sans nous que rien n'a
changé et si tout a changé je rappelle
que nous avons plus de 2 millions de
français qui vivent dans cette zone là
je rappelle que c'est 60% pu dans son
mondial qui vit dans cette zone là je
rappelle que c'est la chine qui sam
chaque jour un peu plus hélas il ne
serait rien passé je pense au contraire
il est temps de partir de 8 ans viser
précisément je pense qu'il faut faire
une faut revisiter la stratégie
française la stratégie française était
basé sur quoi à la fois une alliance
avec l'australie via ce contrat là et il
dénonce avec l'inde notamment via les
rafales toutes ces questions là se pose
parce que dorénavant un sombre deux pays
vont s'interroger sur la solidité
française 2 quand elle signe un contrat
de son matériel et donc ça pose un
centre de question donc la france est
extrêmement fragile mais mises de côté
sur cette zone a donc je pense qu'il est
urgent de revisiter ou d'avoir un
nouveau livre blanc sur la france dans
le milieu indo pacifique
laurence et la priorité à mon avis que
doit avoir allégé dans la région je les
jeux les soigner c'est à dire qu'il ya à
la fois à reprendre l'initiative
politique souveraineté indépendance mais
il ya quand même un versant qui n'a pas
été abordée aujourd'hui dans l'hémicycle
c'est le versant économique se sont
quand même plusieurs milliards d'euros
qui est jean michel lucas cela dit la
pause et un collègue de monde pas posé
la question
donc j'ai pas j'ai pas été suffisamment
attentivement de kayal le versant
économique
et puis je dirais aussi le versant
social parce que c'est 1000 salariés de
naval groupes qui sont finalement dans
l'expectative parce que normalement il
devait effectivement travaillé sur ce
chantier et à partir du moment où le
contrat devient caduque et bien que vont
devenir ces salariés donc nous au niveau
de mon groupe le groupe communistes
républicains citoyens écologistes nous
sommes intervenus sur ses deux versants
c'est à dire que nous soutenons les
salariés nous aimerions aussi avoir des
réponses parce que finalement la
ministre a quand même balayé d'un revers
de main en disant circulez ya rien à
voir il ya deux façons salariés qui sont
aujourd'hui en australie pour le dire un
mot téléspectateurs dominique estrosi
sassone sur 7 sur ses alliances
stratégiques il faudrait peut-être
revoir eric ciotti demande de sortir de
l'otan qu'est ce que vous en pensez vous
moi je ne sais pas si c'est ce qu'il
faut faire en tout cas ce dont je pense
c'est qu'effectivement nos alliés ce
sont les états unis mais rien ne nous
empêche de dialoguer directement avec la
chine avec l'inde de pouvoir rompre avec
la guerre froide avec la russie est en
tout cas également et un collègue du
groupe l'est républicain la halle a
rappelé aujourd'hui dans l'hémicycle en
posant une question comment ne pas faire
le lien entre cette crise des sous
marins américains et le peu d'engagement
même si le ministre le corps nu c'est
offenser a dit que effectivement la
parole était très clair de la part du
gouvernement gamin je trouve que le
gouvernement français ne s'exprime pas
ne réaffirme pas son attachement à la
nouvelle calédonie pour dire que ce
territoire de la république doit rester
français cela à quelques semaines du
troisième référendum définitif sur
l'indépendance je pense que c'est
extrêmement important de la france est
quand même le seul pays européens
présents dans cette zone indo pacifique
et on le voit les démocraties du
pacifique et bien elle s'inquiète de
l'offensive chinoise et on peut aussi
légitimement s'inquiéter par rapport à
demain l'avenir de la nouvelle calédonie
donc c'est vraiment très très important
de pouvoir relier les deux et que le
gouvernement soit plus claire sur
l'avenir que nous souhaitons pour la
nous calédonie sur cette affaire des
sous marins on verra s'il ya une
commission denquête au sénat ou pas et
le président hervé marseille en tout cas
participer hier la conférence des
présidents à l'ordre du jour la création
ou non de cette commission denquête
écoutez c'est au micro de quentin calme
est en salle des conférences
oui effectivement bonjour hervé main
saint geours président du groupe
centriste au sénat d'abord un mot sur
cet incident en séance et florence parly
la ministre mais qui parle d'un sénat
juges et procureurs avec cette idée
d'une commission enquête sur la crise
des sous marins qu'est ce que vous
pensez de cette séquence
je pense que mal à me parler d'un
problème avec le sénat sur son budget
déjà elle nous avait asséné un reprenez
vous messieurs et cette fois ci elle
fustige un sénateur qui posent des
questions sur un sujet majeur bon le
problème c'est pas de mettre en
accusation le gouvernement c'est de
poser des questions sur un problème
extrêmement important le gouvernement
réagit le gouvernement j'espère
maintenant va agir mais c'est la moindre
des choses pour des parlementaires et en
particulier ici au sénat que de poser
des questions auxquelles on attend des
réponses est ce que vous pensez vous de
cette initiative des socialistes qui
demandent une commission d' enquête sur
ce sujet ce que les centristes vont
soutenir cette idée pas je crois que ça
a été évoqué déjà avec le président du
sénat nous avons eu hier une réunion des
présidents et le président cambon le
président de la commission des affaires
étrangères et de la défense a pris des
initiatives d'audition pour ne pas
perdre de temps et il n'est pas
impossible que cette commission se
transforme avec les pouvoirs d'une
commission denquête alors un mot sur un
autre sujet sur lesquels le rôle des
centristes et clé on a vu effectivement
que et bien jean leonetti a remis un
rapport à jal un chai la question jacobs
il préconise et bien l'idée d'une prime
un semi ouverte ouverte notamment à lui
dédie donc vous êtes membre d'un des
membres importants vous saluer cette
idée vous la soutenez les l'air votez
avec les centristes jean leonetti
quelqu'un de très bien c'est un ancien
centriste et donc forcément et il a le
sens de l'histoire et ses racines mais
bon il appartiendra
aux élèves aux républicains à leur
conseil national de décider c'est la
raison pour laquelle pour l'instant nous
n'avons pas pris de position nous sommes
pas mêlés du choix
organisés par les républicains donc
attendons et puis on verra ce qu'il
propose on si il propose une forme
d'ouverture ben on verra si on s'y
associe ou pas d'accord alors ces cas là
vous auriez un candidat vous non mais là
il s'agit pas d'avoir un candidat il
s'agit de participer au choix au vote
donc on va voir quelle est leur décision
quelle est leur conclusion comment tout
ça va s'organiser et puis on verra si
nous participons ou pas mais ce qu'il
faudrait c'est qu'on perde pas de temps
et que maintenant on passe à autre chose
un peu sérieuse un dernier mot sur le
budget qu'il était présenté ce matin en
conseil des ministres et que les
ministres d'ailleurs son dictionnaire à
17 heures on parle d'un budget incomplet
selon pierre moscovici et premier
président de la cour des comptes est-ce
qu'il ya pas un problème démocratique a
examiné un budget à trous pas écouter ça
fait déjà un certain temps qu'on examine
des budget un peu baroque donc si en
plus c'est la cour des comptes qui le
dénonce d'abord j'ai tendance à faire
confiance à la cour des comptes donc on
travaille vous le savez depuis déjà des
mois
et même beaucoup de moi dans des
conditions qui sont difficiles dans
l'urgence on n'a pas le temps de d'aller
au fond des choses on va voir ce budget
les deux budgets d'ailleurs plfss et plf
pourrait qu'on ait la capacité à avoir
un dialogue avec le gouvernement à voir
les vrais chiffres savoir quelles sont
les grandes orientations je crois que
c'est un voeu pieux parce qu'avec les
présidentielle qui s'annonce je pense
que avoir le rythme des dépenses on
n'est pas près de voir le bout de ce
budget
le président du groupe centriste il sera
d'abord répondu à toutes ses questions
merci que senna merci beaucoup quentin
pour revenir encore sur cette crise et
sous main parce que c'est évidemment le
thème le sujet principal de ces
questions d'actualité on a quand même
très peu entendu nos alliés européens
réagir en tout cas très tardivement
comment vous interprétez vous rachetez
mal c'est timidité nos alliés
enfin vous dites une réaction je
rappelle qu aucun chef d'état ou de
gouvernement on a vraiment réagi
sauf un appareil a pas eu de soutien
franc et massif je pense qu'elle deux
choses d'abord il ya une partie de
l'europe notamment d'anciens pays
soviétiques ou de cet ensemble a qui
quand même un rapport aux états unis un
peu différent ménagers l'alliance
américaine pour certains d'entre eux ils
le disent très clairement et après je
crois que c'est tout ça montre également
que nous avons un problème en europe
nous sommes un nain politique et un un
militaire et diplomatique et donc ça
pose la question tu défense commune
européenne je crois que c'est ça qu'il
faut aujourd'hui tranché janvier
prochain présidence française de l'union
européenne c'est l'âme et juin ont joué
les monsieur macron ça fait ça fait
quand même cinq ans qui nous expliquait
dirige l'europe et on voit le résultat
aujourd'hui que ce qui se passe sur les
sur les sous marins c'est comme un échec
de la diplomatie française depuis cinq
ans enfin arrêtons de faire croire que
monsieur macro il a fait de très bon
discours une fois c'est un échec des
manuels macron du gouvernement vous
incriminez dans sa gauche dans son
rapport aux autres pays à sa diplomatie
wii 2 sur wii moi je considère aussi que
cette crise elle affaiblit
considérablement emmanuel macron est ce
que m nl à grand isle responsables de
cette crise a ajouté m je pense que on
peut considérer que aujourd'hui on voit
combien la position de la france
s'affaiblit combien la voix de la france
ne porte pas et de fait la france est
seule et donc ça aussi des conséquences
et tout cela est aussi
ce qui s'est passé depuis le début de la
mandature d'emmanuel mâcon oui je pense
que ce qui est quand même important à
souligner en quelques mots c'est que il
ya une question d'indépendance de la
france une question de place de la
france dans l'europe et dans le monde et
il ya le fait que depuis maintenant
quelques années il ya le gouvernement
macron d précédemment également y avait
eu quand même un certain nombre de
concessions pour ne pas dire plus fait
aux états unis on est complètement
inféodée aux états unis avec toutes les
conséquences que cela peut avoir donc là
ça se ressent parce qu'il ya
effectivement cette actualité mais c'est
quelque chose qui est on à renoncer à
l'indépendance de la france et a parlé
haut et fort il ya qu à voir d'ailleurs
quand on interprète quand on interpelle
pardon le ministre le drian sur quelques
questions que ce soit c'est toujours un
un langage extrêmement diplomatique mais
pas d'intervention je pense ce qui se
passe je revois de la palestine israël
avec anis temps etc il ya plein de
choses qui qui ne collent pas et je
pense que voilà il ya là trois ans
le contrat qu'on évoque ce que seydou
cissouma 56 milliards d'euros donc si on
considère comme l'a fait la ministre que
circuit à n'avoir pour un contrat de 56
milliards d'euros le contrat du siècle
je suis très inquiet quant à leur
gestion des deniers publics il faut
qu'on avance on va aller voir jean
m'assieds tout de suite jean macé on va
refaire les kag eric vous qu'est ce que
vous avez retenu vous et votre
communauté et bien de cette séance cet
après midi ben écoute ci vont à vue tous
florence parly s'énerver à la question
de racheter mal qui est sur votre
plateau d'ailleurs racheté mal le
sénateur qui voilà posé une question
assez simple sur les leçons à tirer de
cette crise et de ce camouflet pour la
diplomatie française et la ministre de
la défense la ministre des armées qui
s'est énervé on la sentait acculé on la
sentait dos au mur on imagine que ses
nuits sont courtes en ce moment on peut
le comprendre mais c'est vrai que les
internautes ont trouvé qu'elle était un
peu monter dans les tours un peu
rapidement et que ça en disait long
finalement sur la décrépitude en fait
pour la diplomatie française et pour
réponse au ministère a elle aussi que
cette affaire des sous-marins et en même
temps dans sa réponse ya aussi eu des
éléments qui ont intéressé les
internautes notamment lorsqu'elle a
rappelé que la question de la défense la
question de l'autonomie stratégique sera
menu de la présidence française de
l'union européenne qui commencera en
janvier prochain et donc on a un peu
hâte en fait avec les internautes ont
hâte de savoir quelle va être la suite
de cette histoire comment va se
recomposer peut-être une europe de la
défense a été annoncée par ursula von
der leyen dans son discours sur l'état
de l'union voila voila un petit peu
l'état d'esprit des internautes sur
cette séance aujourd'hui merci beaucoup
jean durant cette séance il a aussi été
question de des harkis on sait que lundi
emmanuel macron a demandé pardon aux
harkis il a aussi annoncé la fois la
présentation d'un projet de loi
d'indemnisation de réparation pour les
familles de harkis la ministre des
armées a été interrogé aujourd'hui acier
je vous vous à l'écouté et ensuite vous
ferait réagir
soudainement et peut-être je dis bien
peut-être à quelques mois des élections
le souvenir rejaillit à l'elysée le
président macron demande pardon aux
harkis au nom de l'état avec une
nouvelle loi de réparation oui monsieur
le président les arts qui mérite que
leurs souffrances soient reconnus ils se
sont battus pour la france et la france
les abandonner cercle en même temps et
votre marque de fabrique mais sur même
temps mémorielle est particulièrement
malvenu l'objectif du président de la
république est l'objectif que je me suis
assignées pendant ces quatre années où
quatre années un peu plus de quatre ans
est justement de faire en sorte que ces
mémoires se parlent
qu'elles soient toutes respectées et
qu'elle se respectent entre elle et nous
ferons le point de tout ça notamment
lorsque nous parlerons de la loi sur les
harkis proposée par le président de la
république et je crois que ce débat doit
être un débat apaisé respectueux digne
pas encore de précisions sur le contenu
du texte de loi qui sera présenté avant
la fin de l'année a racheté mal vous
avez été convaincu par cette réponse de
la ministre aujourd'hui alors papa sa
réponse mais parle je suis lundi
alizée jacotey et donc moi je feins il
ya deux choses d'abord un il faut que je
rappelle que les harkis ce sont des
soldats français abandonnés par la
france en neuf cent mille au total et
quand ils sont arrivés en france traiter
franchement c'est une honte pour notre
pays ce qu'ils ont vécu des drames
humains qui aujourd'hui de 60 à 80 mille
personnes oui je sais c'était quand même
inhumain enfermés dans des camps etc ce
n'est pas acceptable pour une démocratie
pour moi je pense qu'il est temps
effectivement de reconnaître ce qu'a
fait la france ça foot et de d'avoir une
réparation encore une fois réparations
et des guillemets donc moi je crois
qu'une loi ce qui est annoncé qu'ils
permettent à la fois de faire de la
reconnaissance et la réparation est une
bonne chose après il ya plusieurs
mémoires sur la guerre d'algérie soyons
honnête et c'est ça la difficulté je
croyais à la mémoire des rapatriés la
mémoire des harkis il y avait moi aussi
des appelés du contingent et celle de
des algériens qui sont arrivés en france
après qu'ils sont jolis français je
crois que ces mémoires l'a parfois sont
craints dect contradictoires parfois
complémentaires il faut vraiment pas les
opposer et je crois que ce qu'on doit
faire collectivement c'est de dire
qu'elle existe tout elles sont toutes
respectables il faut les reconnaître et
je crois que c'est ça qu'il faut avoir
ce chemin là en regardant de l'histoire
dans les yeux et moi c'est ce que
j'appelle de mes voeux avec cette voix
là et j'espère j'espère
je rappelle que le président chirac le
présent sarkozy présent l'ont déjà
reconnu et se sont déjà excusé mais
j'espère que la loi annoncée sera mise
en oeuvre vraiment il réellement parce
que je crois qu il ya des centaines de
milliers de français concernés qui doit
tomber dominique estrosi sassone sur ce
projet de loi qu'on annonce qu
électoraliste pas électoraliste
bienvenue pas bienvenus forcément
bienvenues mais forcément également
électoraliste la droite cela fait
plusieurs années qu'elle demande un
geste fort de reconnaissance à l'endroit
des descendants de harkis qui ont
sacrifié leur vie et qui se sont engagés
aux côtés de la france c'est une réalité
donc il est normal aussi qu'il y
aujourd'hui une juste réparation donc ce
projet de loi est le bienvenu les mots
du président la république de demande de
pardon à l'endroit des harkis sont des
mots justes mais certes il ya la
responsabilité de la france sur
l'abandon des harkis sur les conditions
atroces dans lesquelles les harkis ont
été accueillis ici mais pour autant la
france n'est pas la seule responsable de
cette tragédie moi je dis aussi que
l'algérie doit rendre des comptes
jarlard chine dit la chose suivante oui
à la reconnaissance des tragédies mais
non à la repentance ans kohn qu'est ce
que vous en pensez alors d'abord moi
j'étais pas invité à l'élysée donc la
réception de la nation je suis jeune
mais voilà donc en tout cas j'ai j'ai lu
ce qu'a dit le président de la
république moi je considère que c'était
un geste important que ces mots étaient
bienvenus attendue mais qui sont
totalement insuffisant si ça n'est pas
suivi d'actes et ce cas là ce qui me
gêne c'est que on annonce un projet de
loi moi j'aimerais bien que l'on parle
le langage la vérité vu l'inflation
législative qu'on a jusqu'aux
présidentielles je ne vois pas à quel
moment nous allons pouvoir examiner ce
projet de loi et je pense que c'est très
très lourd de conséquences quand le
président de la république dit on va
faire un projet de loi sans précisions
supplémentaires alors qu'on sait très
bien qu'on va être en suspension
parlementaire fin février et que en
attendant il ya beaucoup de projets de
loi que nous devons examiner notamment
le budget de l'état et le budget social
c'est que je passe de campagne quoi
c'est pour le prochain préfet vient
écouter peut-être que je me trompe mais
je ne vois pas très bien comment les
choses vont pouvoir être concrétisés et
donc j'attire l'attention de chacun et
chacune pour être vigilant parce que si
le président de la république se
contente seulement des paroles qui
étaient importantes
ça ne va pas du tout suffire et il y
aura un fort mécontentement justifié qui
va se développer parmi notamment la
communauté des harkis alors qu'est ce
que ce texte doit contenir très
précisément racheter mal selon vous
abbas ou le mans à ce qui a été annoncé
plus d'ailleurs par le président qui par
sa ministre aujourd'hui c'est une
commission nationale qui va permettre
d'abord à toutes les mémoires des harkis
d'être entre guillemets déposé donc les
témoignages des harkis de leurs enfants
et puis qui versailles aura une
réparation forcément financières et avec
un son de mesure des personnes
concernées c'est ce qui est annoncé je
crois encore une fois qu'il faut que
chaque à garder à l'esprit que la
question de la mémoire c'est du domaine
des historiens et nous sommes pas là
pour faire la mémoire est créé à la
mémoire française et l'histoire
française c'est les historiens nous
c'est pour avoir un processus de
reconnaissance publique et encore une
fois nous allons pouvoir travailler avec
des historiens c'est ce que vous dites
sinon ce sont deux choses différentes je
dis que l'histoire ce domaine c'est un
mais je partage comme disent mes
collègues dire que moi maintenant ce qui
m'importe c'est après avoir a quand même
vécu pour les harkis dans des conditions
épouvantables
que la promesse cette promesse soit
tenue et donc avant la fin de l'année le
texte soit voté dans les deux assemblées
et que la commission se met en place
c'est ça l'engagement du président et
j'espère qu'il va il va tenir son
engagement dominique estrosi sassone
qu'est ce que vous en attendez vous de
ce texte mais je pense comme comme mes
collègues et moi je suis aussi inquiète
parce qu'aujourd'hui on voit bien que ça
semble difficile d'examiner ce projet de
loi dans aussi une situation
d'apaisement de pouvoir bien travailler
et aujourd'hui l'ordre du jour il est
déjà pratiquement complets
donc je rapproche aussi d'autres
d'autres annonces fait par le présent
république c'est la même chose sur les
bords de la sécurité aujourd'hui toutes
les annonces qu'a fait le président de
république la semaine dernière sur le
bobo de la sécurité d'abord elles sont
largement incomplète mais au-delà de ça
on voit mal comment tout cela va pouvoir
se mettre en oeuvre et on sait très bien
qu'il y a aucune mesure qui ne pourra
prendre effet avant la fin de cette
mandature donc peut-être malheureusement
ça risque aussi d'être le cas pour cette
loi de reconnaissance et de réparation à
l'endroit des harkis et de leurs
descendants alors au début de l'année
prochaine 2022 ce sera aussi
l'anniversaire des 60 ans de la fin de
la guerre d'algérie à quoi eh bien ces
cérémonies de ressembler selon vous le
ans cohen
écoutez je pense la ministre on a parlé
dans l'hémicycle oui la ministre en a
parlé et après je crois que là on se
focalise à juste titre contenu du
discours du président de la république
sur la réparation à l'égard des harkis
de tous la bonne utilisation de ce sujet
peut-être à la proche de la
présidentielle écouter de toute façon il
faut il faut il faut il faut pas être
naïf c'est à dire que tout sujet
aujourd'hui que nous abordons va être
instrumentalisés à la lumière de
l'élection de l'élection présidentielle
donc on peut le déplorer mais n'empêche
que ça va se faire comme ça bon je pense
que et on le sait au niveau de la guerre
d'algérie la france a quand même très
n'est pas mal les pieds pour
reconnaître la politique de colonisation
à l'égard de l'algérie d'une manière
générale ce qui s'est fait les exactions
etc on voit qu'il ya encore des plaies
qui sont qui sont ouvertes donc je pense
qu'il ya encore du chemin à parcourir
sur sur cette question bien évidemment
moi je souhaite que les choses se
fassent toujours dans l'apaisement et
que ça ne soit pas instrumentalisé à des
fins politiques mais on est quand même
dans une période politique où tous
sujets abordés risque d'être utilisés
agité mal à moi je suis président du
groupe d'amitié france algérie au sénat
c'est pour ça que moi très honnêtement
je crois que du côté français un pas
important a été fait que le rapport de
magenta ce torrent
j'avais tout le monde derrière le lire
pour imiter parfois des fantasmes ou des
choses parce que moi ce que j'aimerais
c'est que cette occasion du 60ème et
sert de la fin de la guerre d'algérie
soit la chance d'avoir un traité
d'amitié entre les deux peuples parce
que je pense que il y à une communauté
de destin entre les deux peuples et je
rappelle juste d'un mot que nous avons
besoin d'algérie notamment sur ce qui se
passe au mali et dans le sahel donc moi
j'appelle un traité d'amitié pour la
jeunesse de pays parce que je crois que
c'est une chance que les deux les deux
parcs des deux peuples se parlent donc
j'espérais avoir un traité pour l'avenir
entre d'amitié entre les deux peuples et
dominique estrosi sassone en 15 secondes
sur 7 sur ses 60 ans de la fin de la
guerre d'algérie sur un sujet aussi
sensible que ça permettez moi de dire
que je pense que le en même temps du
gouvernement peut être extrêmement
compliqué et je crains effectivement que
l' équilibre que la ministre nous a
annoncé dans l'hémicycle ne puisse pas
forcément être trouvée même si on a
senti qu'il y avait une volonté d'ouvrir
une lepage de la mémoire mais c'est
important aussi de savoir que ce qui
s'est passé au moment des accords
d'evian et combien cette mémoire est
toujours resté à fleur de peau en
particulier vis-à-vis de nos rapatrier
des pieds noirs et des pieds noirs merci
beaucoup merci à tous les trois merci
d'avoir accepté
d'être venu sur ce plateau pour refaire
les cas que c'est la fin de cette
émission tout de suite vous avez rendez
vous avec le général georgelin c'est lui
qui est en charge de piloter la
restauration de notre dame de paris
cette restauration doit intervenir d'ici
à 2024 date fixée par emmanuel macron
pour la réouverture de la cathédrale le
général georgelin était au sénat ce
matin pour faire un point d'étape sur ce
chantier il était devant la commission
de la culture je vous propose de revivre
cette audition regarder
alors évidemment depuis le 20 janvier
beaucoup de choses se sont passées sur
le chantier la cathédrale
les interventions liées à la
sécurisation qui ont débuté dans la nuit
même de l' incendie se sont donc achevée
dans le courant de l'été
l'objectif que nous nous étions fixés
pour mettre fin à cette phase délicate
et non tenues il faut le souligner la
cathédrale où l'avait dit et désormais